This is Jocko podcast with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo and tonight's podcast is a little bit different but I think it
has some good information in it.
I was asked by two people who have outstanding podcasts of their own to sit down
and have a conversation about leadership and specifically leadership inside of
atrocities and when we recorded it,
I wasn't really expecting it,
but we decided that we would all release it on our podcast platforms.
So the two people that I recorded this with,
our Danieli Bolelli and Daryl Cooper,
unfortunately Echo Charles was not present for this recording
and Danieli Bolelli.
First of all,
he's a history professor,
he's a martial artist,
he's an author and yes,
he's a podcaster.
He has two podcasts that are great to listen to.
Their great podcast.
One is called the drunk and towers and the other one is history on fire.
They're great podcasts there,
entertaining podcasts,
they're educational,
they're like I said,
they're super informative and the podcast that you're about to listen to is
based on a couple of other podcasts.
The first one being bye Daniellie from his history on fire podcast number 32
Alpha 32 a for civilians out there and the the podcast is about the sand creek
massacre which took place in present day Kiowa County Colorado on November 29th,
1864 where there were about somewhere between 70 and 170 Cheyenne,
Arapaho Indians,
mostly women and children
who were slaughtered by a 675 man force of the Colorado us volunteer cavalry,
brutal situation,
horrible situation and like I said,
Danieli.
Billy talks about that on his history on fire podcast number 32 alpha.
The other podcast this is related to is from Darryl Cooper's podcast.
His podcast is called the martyrmade podcast and specifically podcast number 10
it's about the my Lai massacre
and that is when about 500 innocent civilians.
Again,
mostly women and children were murdered and many also raped and mutilated by US
soldiers in Vietnam.
Daryl Cooper is also an incredible podcast.
Her.
He's a great storyteller and he goes through ridiculous,
I would say depths to give all perspectives of a story.
And He,
his podcast martyrmade is fantastic.
He doesn't put them out off as often as I wish he would.
But the podcasts are great.
The one on the Palestinian Israeli conflict that he started his first,
I think it's his first six podcasts on martyrmade.
That's what it's about.
And they're fantastic.
And he's a veteran of the u s navy.
He's a wrestler,
he's a Jujitsu player,
and he's really smart,
well read person and great to listen to.
And then the last podcast is my own podcast,
Jocko podcast number 31 four hours in me lie,
which is when I did an assessment of a book by that name and talked about that
same massacre in Vietnam and in this podcast that you're about to listen to,
the three of us discuss how these atrocities come about and what can be done to
prevent them in the future.
So that's the lay down.
And here it is.
Danieli Jocko,
everybody.
I'm here.
Daryl Cooper,
uh,
talking to two of my favorite people.
Um,
we're going to go some dark places today.
You've listened to the last two podcasts.
It's Daniella and I have put out and maybe about 60% of the podcast that Jocko
was put out.
Then,
you know,
we're going to,
we're going to dive into some dark places.
Um,
I want to get it started pretty quick.
We've been talking beforehand so let's just jump right into it.
Um,
Daniella and I recently did a series that we uh,
cooperated on where he covered the sand creek massacre in 1864 some US army
soldiers,
uh,
massacred some native Americans in Colorado.
Um,
I did the meal Lai massacre,
um,
similar situation 104 years later in the jungles of Vietnam.
Um,
we're fortunate enough to be here with Jocko.
If you don't know who Jocko is a,
I guess we'll go ahead and let you introduce yourself just a little bit.
Yeah,
my name is Jocko Willink.
Guy Was in the military for 20 years and retired in 2010 and now I written a
couple books and have a podcast called Jocko podcast cause I don't get really
creative with the names of things.
So
jacos pretty direct about things.
So I,
he's also kind of humbled.
Jocko is a navy seal commander in Iraq.
He led taskforce bruiser is that right into a task unit.
Bruiser bruiser into the battle of Ramadi.
She,
if you know anything about the war in Iraq,
you know,
the battle of Ramadi in the battle of Fallujah are probably the two big fights
that get mentioned the most.
Whereas Fallujah was more of an more of a direct assault on the city after,
uh,
after the insurgents captured and tortured and mutilated some US contractors and
Bush ordered the Marines to retaliate.
The battle of Ramadi was a little bit different.
Uh,
Jack was going to talk a little bit about the environment that they went into,
uh,
going into it.
And so he's got some military experience,
not only being on the ground,
but of leading men in battle in an environment and insurgent war where you've
got different groups of people,
different sex,
the Sunni and the Shia Anorak who are fighting a bloody battle that we're in the
middle of,
but who we can engage with on their level.
You know,
these are people who are fighting a very,
very dirty and ugly war against one another and against us if they get their
hands on us as Americans,
I'm going into a war like that.
You know,
we've got,
we've got a different mentality and we try to avoid behaving in ways that
dishonor us.
And uh,
it's something that Jocko takes very seriously and he had to let lead men into
combat under those conditions.
So we can talk about that.
It was 2006,
April of 2006 when you lead you men into Ramadi to begin with,
is that right?
Yes,
that's what it was.
So shortly before that,
a couple of months before the golden dome of the Alis scarred mosque was blown
up by al Qaeda in Iraq.
Zarqawi is people,
uh,
this is an ancient Shia mosque,
one of the most sacred places to,
to Shia Islam?
Well,
well,
interestingly,
Ramadi was,
is primarily Sunni.
In fact,
it's almost all SUNY and interestingly the majority of the military forces in
Iraq,
especially the army were Shia.
And so you had to kind of diffuse that tension on a pretty regular basis to make
sure that there weren't,
you know,
reprisal killings and the,
there was definitely some level of mistrust between the Sunni's that lived there
in the city and the Shia military.
But it's definitely,
it's,
it's absolutely,
it was absolutely clear that the,
the Sunni's that lived in Ramadi,
the local Sunni's that lived in Ramadi,
much preferred the Shia army soldiers to the insurgents that were there that
were being run by al Qaeda in Iraq by Zarqawi and the likes.
And because what they were doing was just savagery and you know,
everything that you hear about,
they were skinning people alive.
They were beheading whole families.
They were torturing,
raping,
and murdering,
murdering the local populace in to get them to support them as much as they
could through pure terror.
And so the local populace,
even though they might not have been,
you know,
they're,
they're basically going with who's their worst enemy at the time.
Their worst enemy at the time was without question al Qaeda in Iraq.
And so the she army that was there to fight al Qaeda in Iraq,
the Sunni's or we're generally in support of what the army was doing there.
So it was,
it was a little bit different than an areas like solder city where the,
the,
she is in solder city,
we're very active.
There was an active fight going on against coalition forces.
So yeah,
it's uh,
it's definitely a tricky situation
when you,
when you roll into a situation like that with American soldiers where both sides
are engaged in just a hurricane of atrocities across the country and where the
people who are there,
they might be looking to you for safety or I guess that's a question I would
have a,
they probably under the circumstances where the people in the city,
I mean they probably were looking to you to protect them.
Absolutely.
And just before we showed up,
just to,
just to kind of paint this as clear as I can and,
and I forget the exact numbers and I apologize for that,
but just before we showed up,
the insurgents murdered,
it was something like seven,
eight,
nine 10 of the leading tribal shakes in the area and the tribal shakes that
survived for that left,
they left.
And so that just put the whole,
the whole city,
you know,
under such a grip of fear of the insurgents that they just basically surrendered
as much as you can surrender,
which means,
hey,
if you want to come and stay at my house and you want to sit in my backyard and
launch mortars at the coalition forces,
we're not going to say anything to you because we're going to,
we want to live,
we don't want to get killed.
And that's what you end up with.
You end up with passive support.
And that's what the locals were doing.
They were passively supporting the insurgents only because they didn't want to
have their heads cut off.
And so as we,
and this was a brilliant strategy that was spearheaded by the one one AED,
the ready First Brigade of the First Armored Division run by a guy named Colonel
Sean Mcfarlin,
who ended up being a general,
and he's a brilliant guy and,
and a great leader,
but you know,
his eye,
his attitude,
which he actually got from HR McMaster,
which he had employed up in California.
And uh,
one,
one 80 had actually gone into Californ,
gotten a turnover and understood what they had done up and Telefonica.
And,
and the strategy was called cs clear hold and build,
which was going to be his enemy,
controlled territory's these enemy controlled neighborhoods and stay there.
And so that's what,
that's what the strategy was.
And that was a lot different then the strategy that had been being used up until
this point,
not just in Ramadi button.
All of Iraq
is that strategy that's,
um,
it almost seems like,
uh,
looking at reading about Ramadi from the outside of somebody who's never been in
combat,
it almost seems like the goal was to go in there and establish your dominance
over the city.
Almost to show the people of the city that you don't have to be afraid of these
people because they afraid of us and we're gonna,
we have freedom in this city.
We can take our Humvees and patrol these streets and they're not going to come
out and fight us because they're afraid of us.
And so you don't have to fear them.
It almost seems like that was the goal there.
Yeah.
I wouldn't use the word dominance because we weren't trying to dominate the
local populace.
We were trying to provide security for the local population.
And obviously that's a big difference because when you start having an attitude
of we're going to dominate the local populace,
that that's just a small step in the wrong direction.
Right?
That's a small step in the wrong direction.
Whereas saying,
Hey,
we're here to protect and secure and stabilize the local populace,
that is,
that is what we were doing.
Yeah.
I think it took us maybe a little bit longer than we wish it would have to,
uh,
recognize that before you can do anything counterinsurgency,
you have to provide security to the people from to percent.
You're not leaving them a choice,
then they're going to provide that passive support.
Right.
And I think that's one of the issues that shows up with the kind of episodes we
did.
You know both the story of Sand Creek and story off me lie.
You have a c to a shooting,
which sad than the,
some guys begin to look everybody on the quote unquote add their side as
belonging to the same field.
The Hawaii because they are all Cheyenne or they are old Vietnamese,
they are all,
there's no signs that they are not all in the same boat.
Some people are your allies,
some people are your enemies.
Some people are exactly what you are saying.
Stacking between where I kind of have to cooperate with your enemies,
not because I want to buy because I really have no other choice and you cannot
treat all of them the same way.
And so I think the dilemma you are facing these idea of having to figure out,
okay,
there are people that we're here to protect.
Those are not the people we're going after.
There are other people that we need to take care of.
That seems to be one of the scenes.
There was Betty match me scene,
you know that nuance,
that ability to look at people who may look the same way but they are not the
same people to look at them it with different eyes.
That seemed to be really well was me seeing some of the stories,
no wheat treated where the guys who did what they did is because to damn is like
an Indiana,
he's an Indian,
Vietnamese,
whatever.
It's all the same.
Doesn't really matter.
And I think he's like ow do you see one leads to that point on one side and vice
versa.
What is the you guys were doing to make sure that it doesn't go to that point
where's your guys would not make that switch to that frame of mind and keep it
there.
[inaudible] Betty clear in terms of differentiating in terms of who they are
facing
real quick.
Can I just add a supplement to that question?
Cause that's kind of what I wanted to ask as well as,
uh,
how do you,
how do you train your men and lead your men in such a way that they can pull the
trigger when they have to and when civilians get killed on,
you know,
accidentally that that doesn't destroy them emotionally.
Right?
There's gotta be some kind of separation there without having them fully enter
over into that mindset that Danielle,
he's talking about where you're just dehumanizing the enemy all together when
you have to lead your men in a situation like that.
Like how,
how do you,
how did you deal with that?
Yeah.
Well this is leadership.
This is leadership and this is leadership in war.
And this is,
you know,
this,
this question that you're asking is the,
is the,
you know,
one of the largest possible questions you could ask about combat leadership and
I appreciate that you guys keep referring to me,
but I was,
I had 35 or 40 seals there depending on the time and there was 5,600 soldiers
and marines that were there that were discriminating targets every single day
and that had outstanding leadership that we're,
that we're making sure that guys with less training than my guys,
guys that were younger than my guys,
guys that had a tougher job than my guys in many cases would still discriminate
targets and make sure that they were,
were engaging enemy personnel and not civilians.
Now I'm certainly not saying that civilians didn't get killed because civilians
got killed and it's an awful thing.
And one of the things I talk about all the time,
if you go to war and you're not comfortable with the fact that you're going to
kill innocent some people,
then you probably don't have the will to go to war.
And maybe what you're going to war for isn't,
doesn't meet the threshold of what warrants a war.
And,
and if that's what the conclusion you come to,
that's fine.
You know,
let's hope you come to it before you've,
before you've been on before you're on the ground and,
and blood has been spilled.
But there's so many little things to that.
Would,
that would,
that,
you know,
that we'd cover to talk about,
I mean,
just even the distinction that I just made between like,
hey,
we're,
we're going in there to dominate.
That's a little step.
It's one little step and using that word and then following it up.
And we talked a little bit about this and Daryl,
I was listen to your podcast about the meal.
I'm asking her and I,
and I did one about it as well.
And one of the things that,
that really,
that I talked about in pretty great depth because for me I had,
I had incredible correlate correlation between what happened in me life and what
I sometimes saw happen overseas.
And that was with the intelligence that you're receiving.
And you could see,
and I pointed it out in my podcast and I,
I don't remember like all the exact verbiage,
but you know,
at the senior levels of intelligence,
the intelligence report was that Pinkville or the area of Pinkville or me lie
whenever you want to call it me lie for that,
that area,
the,
the initial intelligence was,
you know,
suspected Vietnamese in the or suspected Viet Cong,
uh,
area could be possible,
you know,
Vietcong.
And then it went down one level in the chain of command and the next people that
briefed it,
it was,
you know,
just a little bit stronger.
You know,
it was
v,
you know,
Vietcong area,
Vietcong controlled area,
and then it went down one more level and it was Viet Cong,
uh,
headquarters area.
And then it got down to,
this is all Vietcong and then they threw in the,
the fact that,
you know,
the,
the people going to the market,
right?
It's market day,
you know,
that started off as,
hey,
some people will be at the market on this day.
And by the time it got to the guys on the ground it was every one that's good is
going to be at the market.
Everyone that's still in the village is going to be bad.
They're going to be VC and well you know what to do with VC.
Yeah.
What'd he say is,
he said really interesting in terms of just human communication.
Oh,
in that case,
before you even go about Americans and Vietnamese,
you even discuss who are or lead.
Just the basics of human communication.
Now sometime stark dean one degree off.
Before you know it,
if you keep it long enough,
the one degree off to Q so far off course from the reality they are trying to
describe that the wards switch,
he's kind of like playing telephone.
You know when you,
we spare something in the other person's theory doesn't sound that different
from what you just third by.
You just tweak a tiny beat by the time you're down 20 people.
The message as no similarity whatsoever to the regional one.
And it seems like that as I think we do,
we told the time in daily life,
but nobody dies as a result of its.
Whereas in that Chi kind of scenario,
people do die.
And the consequences are so much more dramatic as a result of that.
And what's interesting is,
and Darryl,
you kind of brought up in your podcast and you did as well,
Daniel,
is how does this happen?
How does this happen?
Because if you take a normal human being and you drop them into the middle of
that thing,
they look around and they go,
what the hell's happening?
Which is,
which is actually what happened when,
uh,
when,
Hugh Thompson came in his helicopter,
he,
he dropped into this situation and said,
what the Hell's going on here?
This is totally wrong.
Uh,
but as you're,
as you're getting there,
if you're not on that trip,
if you're not on that train as it's going off the rails,
you,
you don't recognize it.
And that's why one thing I talk about all the time from a leadership perspective
is the ability to detach from all the chaos and all the mayhem that's happening.
Because if you don't have to,
if you don't have the ability to detach from that chaos,
you're in it.
And if you're in the chaos as a leader,
you don't see the mayhem that's happening.
And so it's so important for a leader in the business world,
but certainly in the military,
to be able or in any leadership position,
to be able to step back and,
and observe what's actually happening from a detached perspective.
Because otherwise you're in the storm.
And that is not a good place to be as a leader.
You've got to have rules for how you're going to behave before while you're
going into it.
Because if you just,
you know,
if you're going to react to everything on the ground once you arrive,
uh,
I mean,
it's always expedient to just shoot them.
You know,
at the time it's always easier and safer probably to just do the easy thing and
be violent or whatever.
So you have to have rules going into it.
Um,
did you have to guess the one thing that I want,
because the point team bidding stuff is super interesting,
but I think essentially what you're saying is that the person in a position of
leadership needs to be as an master.
You know,
they need to be in the middle of emotions that clearly are affecting everyone
around them and they are bombarded day are getting bombarded windows,
emotions.
They need to be completely detached from this stuff.
It makes perfect sense.
Do you do it?
Cause it's a hell of a lot easier said than done clearly.
And I would do people even terrain to get to that place
so well for one thing,
when I was running the training for the west coast seal teams,
I would fire up that training to a point that it was,
there was total temptation for the leaders to get wrapped into the scenarios
that I was developing for them.
There'd be total mayhem and if they let it happen they would get wrapped up in
these horrible scenarios mentally,
emotionally they'd be mad.
They'd be mad at me.
Cause I was the guy that was running the training.
They'd be mad at the opposing force roleplayers they'd be mad at their guys.
They'd start yelling and screaming.
They'd make bad decisions and,
and I wanted them to get there because I wanted them to see what happens when
you get wrapped up in this stuff emotionally.
So,
and then what I would do is teach them that they have certain,
what I would call red flags,
certain certain signals that they need to learn how to pick up.
Yeah.
If you feel yourself start raising your voice,
well then that probably indicates that you might get be getting emotional if
you're breathing heavy,
if your fists are clenched.
There's all these things that you start to recognize.
And once you can recognize them and you say,
okay,
I'm starting to get emotional right now,
need to step back.
Now interestingly,
what I would often do an easy methodology for training these guys was first of
all,
stop looking down the sides of your weapon like you.
You're not allowed to.
And we'd give,
we'd give a liter of stick if we had to and take their gun away so that they
weren't going to be shooting.
They weren't going to be wrapped up in that tactical situation and literally put
that weapon at high port and step back away from the firing line.
You know Kelly Kelly is with his m 16 gunning people down.
He's completely wrapped up in what's happening.
Medina's yelling and screaming.
I mean I talk about this with,
with police forces as well.
If you want to hear people go,
go listen to some of the bad shootings that you hear and police have a
incredibly hard job.
They need way more training.
But go listen to some of those shootings that take place and listen to the pitch
and the tone of the officer if and,
and what are they doing?
They're saying,
God,
I'm good to get out there.
They're completely emotional and that emotion is going to drive bad decision
making.
So you have to learn how to detach.
The way you do it is in a way I would initially teach guys to do it is by
physically putting their weapon at high port,
stepping back away from the actual firing line and look moving their head around
and looking around.
You know,
so Bob Story I wrote about an extreme ownership is,
you know,
we,
I had w w the,
the Delta platoon commander who's a great guy,
smart guy,
you know,
Ivy League naval academy and just,
just a,
a brilliant guy,
great guy.
And he was,
we were doing some training and it was in Humvees and we were doing immediate
action drills and Humvees here out in the desert.
And your targets pop up and you engage the targets.
It's like,
it's like being mini tank commanders and you've got five vehicles,
you've got to maneuver them on the battlefield while they'd provide cover fire
for each other.
And it's,
it's a little bit chaotic.
There's big machine guns shooting.
And,
and when I was going with him and I was sitting behind him observing him do
this,
and every time the shooting we started,
he would kind of lock up,
right?
He'd kind of like lock up.
There's so much happening that he wasn't processing it quick enough.
And so I took a sharpie magic marker and I,
and I,
and I wrote down,
um,
on the window in front of his face.
I wrote,
here's what I want you to do and when,
when the shooting starts,
I want you to this one,
relax to look around three,
make a call.
And at that time I hadn't thought through this stuff as much as I have now
because I've been doing it for much longer.
But what I was telling him to do was detached from what's happening and the way
you do that,
as you relax,
you look around and,
and then you get on the,
the radio and you make a call and you know,
the next run I watched him and I was sitting behind him and I'm looking over his
shoulder and once the shooting starts,
you can't hear anything.
So I'm just,
just watching him and I,
I see him,
the shooting stars and I seen him look at the window and I seen him take a deep
breath and exhale.
And I was like,
okay,
he just relaxed and I see his head to start turn and I realize,
now he's looking around and,
and that,
those two simple items were enough to make him detach from all that chaos,
actually assess what is happening and then make a good decision.
And so that is one of the most important things that you can train a leader to
do.
Sounds like coaching a Jujitsu white belt.
First thing you tell them that on the ground,
getting beat on and they kind of first,
firstly you tell him,
breathe,
just breathe,
relax.
Until you can do that,
then nothing's going to work.
Yeah,
it's one of those,
it's one of those things to,
people talk about like breathing exercises and one thing that I would
instinctively do,
and it's another thing that I would train my guys to do was like you don't panic
on the radio.
You don't yell on the radio,
you don't scream on the radio.
You,
no matter what's going on,
when you get on the radio you say,
you know bruiser one six,
this is bruiser over.
I mean that's,
that's what you do.
And in order to do that,
you have to relax you.
So it forces you.
If you're not going to sound panicked on the radio,
which if you sound panicked on the radio and,
and your team,
here's it,
guess what?
You're going to have panic going on.
So you have to,
it's another,
it's another method to detach.
So when you hear your voice getting excited,
when you know,
when you're read about lieutenant Calley yelling and you hear about Medina
yelling,
uh,
that,
you know,
Kelly started yelling likely because Medina was yelling at him.
And now that's what happens.
We're just,
we're just sending that panic through the chain of command and it's a,
it's a horrible,
horrible thing.
I think what's fascinating about it is that the parallels,
even through the scenario you artists,
could I be [inaudible] seem the 99% of the people,
at least sitting in 99% of the human beings would never have to deal with
because they are never going to be in combat,
which bullets flying all around them and all of that.
And yet it's easy to forget the deceived dynamics that are at play in most
people lives in ways that they may be able to recognize in the last six stream,
uh,
consequences.
But like when you're a parent and you have your kids going wild,
then suddenly you find yourself,
you know,
raising your voice and starting to yell at them and not the cause.
I mean there's a time and a place sometime is the right thing to do is to kind
of call them on their stuff in harsh ways.
But there's a difference between raising your voice with any intent and raising
your voice because you are losing it and you're getting overly emotional and
they're getting angry and Keith's realize it and they way leader you day we have
see how you are losing your stuff.
They will see how you are less of a credible presence in their life that they
know can count on you that way because you are a rapid in your own emotions and
you know they press a little button and you go off sometime they'll press that
button because they enjoy seeing new golf sometimes.
But you know,
the point is you're not a good leader as a parent.
And it's the same thing.
I mean,
my company now,
we work with businesses all over the world and it's the same exact thing.
And I teach the same exact thing.
If you're starting to get mad at your employee,
you're starting to get mad at your subordinates.
If you're starting to get mad at your boss,
what should you be doing as a good leader?
You should be detaching.
Taking a step back,
I've told people,
hey,
if you start feeling that way,
you stand up from the meeting table.
Just,
just,
you know,
no one's going to say,
Hey,
what are you doing?
You just,
you know,
stand up,
stretch out,
step back away.
These people are having a heated argument and you start getting involved in it
instead of getting involved in it.
Take a step back.
By the way,
when you do that,
you look like a tactical genius because everyone else has started losing their
temper.
They were starting to say things that they shouldn't say.
And you're the one that's listening.
I just just covered a book.
Um,
and,
and just,
just like a little thing is if,
if there's,
if you're talking,
I'm gonna let you talk because if I let you talk,
I know twice as much as you,
I know everything that you know and I know everything that I know,
so I'm going to win that tactical situation.
Um,
I want to come back to what you were just saying,
Daniella about leadership as a parent.
It ties into something he was talking about a few minutes ago with like a police
officer who's panicking.
We were mentioning this on the car ride over here about police shootings.
Like more often than not,
what you see is that they're the result of incompetence.
They're the result of um,
uh,
socially inept cop who can't manage the situation.
And it's not an easy situation to manage.
You've got a potentially dangerous person,
you don't know them and maybe they're lightly resisting you just verbally and
you've got to take control of that situation.
Well,
unless you're an exceptionally competent and confident person,
it may be the only tool you have to bring that person under control is your
baton or whatever it is.
And,
um,
you get the impression in Vietnam,
especially once you get up to 68,
69 where you know,
they're starting to just throw junior officers and right out of,
you know,
ROTC and just throwing them into combat and you hear,
uh,
stories about,
you know,
officer's getting fragged.
You start to hear stories about Cali washed out ocs three,
three times,
right?
And you,
uh,
you get these people now into a situation where you have a military unit that
recognizes they're incompetent leadership and they're scared.
They feel incompetent themselves as a unit.
Um,
and you get them into a place where,
uh,
and maybe this is something that you can contrast really well because you dealt,
you led primarily,
uh,
seals and marines,
right?
Seals joke.
It just hits you.
And you worked a lot with marines,
the marines and army soldiers as well.
Okay.
Yeah.
And mostly there was one battalion of marines in inside Ramadi.
Okay.
The three,
eight marines.
Awesome.
When you're dealing with,
uh,
the American military today.
And I know,
I mean,
um,
something that'll,
it gets lost on a lot of people is that,
uh,
as highly trained and motivated and all those things as our special forces are,
you know,
they're very specialized.
You guys are,
you know,
trained for very,
very specific intense missions and stuff.
But you go pull an average ranger or marine or something or infantry men,
uh,
you put them in combat with good leadership and that is a unbelievably effective
soldier.
I mean,
American soldiers today are all volunteer force.
These are incredibly well trained and motivated people if you know,
if they have the proper leadership.
Uh,
when,
when you get back into a situation like that with Vietnam,
where you get a whole unit in that situation that,
that cops in,
where they're in maybe a village,
they don't exactly know how to handle this situation without resorting to lethal
force.
And they start to feel threatened and everything runs off the rails.
You know,
it's,
it's unrealistic to expect,
just like,
uh,
you know,
you're happily married man,
and you don't want to cheat on your wife.
Then when you're off on a business trip,
uh,
after you've had a few drinks with the coworker that's on travel with you,
um,
it seems innocuous.
Maybe it's totally innocent at the time.
Don't go upstairs to the hotel to watch a movie because if you get to that
point,
you're just putting yourself in a terrible position.
Right?
And,
and in an a,
in that military context,
the idea that all of the built up momentum behind something like me lie,
the idea that you're going to get right up to that moment on March 16th,
1968 where the only thing that's stopping it from happening is a few pounds a
trigger pull.
That's the last bit of,
you know,
that's your last opportunity to avert this catastrophe is just that few pounds a
trigger pull.
Good luck with that.
You know,
that's something that you can't let it get to that point.
And that was something that,
uh,
and then I'll let you guys take it over.
But I wanted to talk about something that it was fascinating to me that you
picked up on.
As soon as I said the word establish dominance on the streets or Ramadi,
you reacted against that.
And you're right.
That's incredibly important.
And it ties into what you were just talking about,
about you would make people,
uh,
either back away from the situation or stop looking down the sites of their gun.
Because when you're looking at a person down the sights of your gun,
it's your framing of the situation and you haven't put down their gun.
And now it's just a person.
It's not a target.
It's not anything like that.
Uh,
if you got a bunch of people going into Ramadi and they're thinking in terms of
our job is to go establish dominance on the streets of this city,
well,
you're framing that in a way that under the right circumstances could,
uh,
you know,
lead to trouble.
And so framing it seems like it's,
is what you're talking about.
And,
and I also want to make it perfectly clear that if the soldiers,
marines,
seals that we work with in the battle of Ramadi,
if they didn't dominate the street as we move down it,
you know,
we would be just be,
oh,
we be killed.
So there is,
the job is even harder than I made it out to say to be because I don't,
I w I wouldn't want to use the word dominate the city of Ramadi,
but you're damn right,
we're going to dominate the space that we go into and we're going to do that by
being very,
very aggressive.
And so there is this fine line,
and by the way,
you'd go into a,
you'd kick a kick a door in,
in Ramadi,
and there's,
there's gunfire in the street that you're on.
You'd kick in a door and there would be a mom and a dad and a couple of kids and
there'd be a normal household with green grass and a soccer balls.
And that would happen that that's what the city was filled with.
And so the,
the fact that these guys,
you know,
were able to flip that switch over and over and over again was,
was amazing.
And it's a,
it's a testament to,
to the military forces that we have and to the leadership.
I want to give equal credit to both.
But to your point about,
hey,
you know me lie,
these were draftees.
There was hundreds of thousands of draftees that went over there and did an
incredible job.
They were well led,
that stood up when people win,
when the wrong things were happening.
So this was a horrible scenario.
Okay,
Daniella,
let's follow up on that then.
I mean,
that's,
cause that's what's the difference?
Like what happens,
um,
you didn't get all the psychopaths in the army and round them up into one unit,
right?
Um,
by all accounts,
the guys at me lie,
uh,
talked to you.
They were the type of people that when the folks back in Kansas heard about what
happened,
they couldn't believe that little Johnny would ever do anything like that.
Same thing at Sand Creek.
Right.
Same thing.
And so
because you're right,
we were talking about this on the way to something today.
It is a for,
we have something like Abu Ghraib happens.
It's a terrible situation.
A lot of bad things went on there.
The idea though that an entire company of American soldiers would go into an
Iraqi village and wipe out 500 innocent people that is inconceivable today,
uh,
in,
in the sense that so many things would have to go wrong and break down and
degrade and degenerate in the American military for that to have happened that
it's just,
it seems like a completely different moral universe.
And
you look at what the chain of events that led to me lie.
It was those and if any of those chain of events,
any anywhere along that chain of events could have broken that whole chain.
Lieutenant Calley could've gotten killed when the field and now you could add
someone else came in that was a better leader and didn't have a Napoleon complex
and was able to stand up more lead to other people.
There's,
there's so many things that could have changed on that,
you know,
that could have changed that whole scenario.
The most,
the most powerful one being a different leaders.
Same thing at Sand Creek,
different leader that that actually never would have happened.
Right?
I'm never would have happened.
And you see that,
you know,
you see all the guys on their side lost soul like you 90 Mosley,
they all agree with team where I was all the guys we achieving United,
it's like clearly there's a leadership element where the average guy in those
units is heavily influenced by WHO's setting an example for them.
And that sees one of the scenes that interests me about human nature that,
you know,
one of the things cause we were discussing like does that mean that human being,
you know one of the things too,
we had our lot with these are human beings just Tivo by nature and he's like,
no they are not evil.
Do Majority of people are now there are of course the exceptions that he's,
that whatever's mold percentage,
but the majority of human beings are not evil.
The problem is that the majority of human being Saturday [inaudible] lien for
once,
like they're more alcohol and plus can arrange him so many do you fit in
direction that and they're right.
Leadership Day will be awesome human beings and the wrong leadership,
he's not that hard for them to start sliding down everybody direct direction.
So to me it kind of is a method of weakness more than evil.
No,
it's not that these guys are a complete psychopath where you know you haven't
been there with them and they are nice people and they yell to the Old Lady
Cross the street and yet the the Getty,
why did,
they may have good intentions,
good intentions don't go too far without crazy DC plans,
throng willpower,
a lot of the qualities that allow you to keep it as good tension real and
they're heavy emotional thresh where he doesn't all fly out the window.
It's like,
I don't know what happened.
I just
lost my mind.
Or Hey,
they told me that this was the thing to do.
And so I just followed orders.
You know where you have that integrity to stay present in a crazy situation.
You're asking human beings to be kind of extraordinary in those circumstances
because the ordinary human being may go down a bad path.
So the antidote in some ways seem to be to make yourself extraordinary,
to be,
to be able to withstand a kind of situation.
And that's where,
and get a,
to lead or make a huge difference because so many people would be like flags in
the wind.
You know,
if the wind is tilting one way,
they will go with a though knowing the Stilton heavily the other way,
they'll also go that route and,
and so that,
what interests me is because while a few humans,
we load always choose a pretty massive dop,
evil side,
a bunch of humans can go either way.
What he's that shape the kind of human beings that we'll be able to be a great
leader or even just for themselves,
even if they are dev nobody under them,
just they will make choices that in an ideal scenario,
most human beings would want to make.
What does separate the guy who,
you know,
he's sitting there on on the couch saying,
oh,
I would beat a guy and a guy [inaudible] that guy.
I think one of the difficulties with that,
um,
is Jocko,
you and Jordan Peterson talked about this and um,
your podcast together.
Um,
you were talking about the book ordinary men and how uh,
you know,
you've got a couple of guys,
group of guys there who are going to,
who are being ordered to do something that's grotesque and it's not simply a
matter of like,
you know,
that's a real good situation.
If,
let's say you are a person of strong moral character of just all the things that
you would want them to be.
You've got two conflicting moral systems here because you have a duty and
obligation to your fellow soldiers who were going to have to go do this one way
or another unless you revolt completely and then you're betraying your country
and there's all these other things that are brought into it that,
you know,
that are moral things.
These are,
you know,
it's moral to not want to abandon your friends and your colleagues to have to go
do the hard work that has to be done so that you can go nurture yourself,
righteous sense of personal morality.
Or at least that's the type of thinking that might go through a person's head.
Like,
what right do I have to put my own personal idea of what's right ahead of my
obligation as a soldier ahead of what my country is telling me to do ahead of,
uh,
just being in there with all of my friends and fellow soldiers and,
and leaving it to them.
Like that's a moral thing.
And that is a,
that is something that you want people to feel.
Right.
And I,
and I,
and I wonder sometimes how much of these situations are filled with people who,
um,
you know,
maybe 90% of them,
the,
the vast majority that aren't those few evil ones,
they're all kind of looking at each other.
Like,
maybe inside they don't necessarily think this is right or B or they don't want
to be doing this but they don't want to abandon their friends and their friends
are looking at them thinking the same thing
and you just have this vicious cycle.
You know the isn't one of these things.
Yeah.
And part of the problem there is the human willingness to rationalize and make
justifications for oneself.
He's like,
well in deck again,
cause you know when you look at the principles that people hold,
like what they believe their philosophy of life is and the way they behave,
even you match more ordinary circumstances.
I mean you made the example of the cheating husband,
right?
How many people seriously believe that monogamy is the right thing and you don't
cheat on your spouse?
There will be lots and lots and lots of people who say,
yeah,
of course I believe in it.
How many people actually live up to it?
And it's like,
come on man,
that's not nobody's shooting at you or nobody.
There are no,
it's a match.
More mellow situation.
And people in many cases can to live up to their ideals in very ordinary
circumstances,
let alone when you start pressing the buttons and when the circumstances are no
longer horrid Ari.
But it's becomes real panic time and stress and all of that goes up.
So to me it's like you need to have almost a maniacal determination to FD
discord of condo that you will hold up no matter what happens.
Like I use it as,
it's a joke,
but it is not a joke.
Like I use it for daily life as like to me once I am very few more other roles
that are absolutes.
But the ones that are,
there are no exceptions.
So for me,
like if you give your word to somebody,
there are no exception.
It's like don't give your word unless you are 110% sure you're going to keep it.
Don't,
I don't mind.
You know,
we can have a regular conversation and you don't give your word,
but if you do give your award to me there is no,
oh sorry.
I didn't think in that situation are there was that exception to me.
The only way you apologize is a summer I style,
you know,
you stick a knife in your belly and use lives back and forth.
That's how you say,
sorry.
There is no exception to that.
It's almost as if,
uh,
you have the,
that those rules serve as pollsters.
When you're in a situation that's as chaotic as something like,
yeah.
Combat where you have to have a few rules that,
I mean maybe they're arbitrary but you'll die for them because when you're in
the midst of a situation that is completely outside the realm of your normal
experience,
uh,
they give you reference points,
you know,
they get,
they structure the situation a little bit for you so you're not just lost in
chaos.
There's some structure to it and then you can evaluate the rest of the
environment relative to those hard and fast rules that you've got.
Because in the situation,
you know when you're in me lie and you're one of the people who's kind of on the
fence,
but now people are shooting,
that is not the time to have this argument with yourself.
No,
that's not when you're going to figure it out.
Yeah,
for sure.
Well this might sound really obvious and it is,
it's a very simple,
obvious answer to this really,
really hard question of how do you prevent this thing from happening or who's
the kind of person that will stand up?
And the answer is it's actually,
it's quite simple.
It's training and education,
it's training
and education.
And if people understand that these kind of things can happen and they get put
in these pressers situations and they get trained and they get debriefed on
mistakes that they made and they saw that they got emotional and you train them
correctly,
well then you've got someone who gets into a me lies situation and and says to
themselves,
wait a second,
we're not getting shot at right now.
Cease Fire.
And,
and that was the most incredible thing about that story is that's all it took
was a one leader to say,
hey,
stop killing people.
And they,
they literally stopped at that moment.
So training people and putting them in these situations and educating them so
that they understand so that they have pattern recognition,
training them so that they can learn how to detach,
training them so that they can control their emotions,
training them,
that they can see when horrible things are unfolding before them and then how
that they,
they can put a stop to them.
That is what is important.
And as you mentioned,
Daryl,
as the,
as the Vietnam War drove on,
that the training got less and less than that.
The officers were getting sent over quicker and quicker and you're getting on
the job training and the person that you're getting on,
on the job training from is a person that's only been doing it for two and a
half months longer than you.
And that's,
that's how these things occur.
So you have to invest in,
in,
in people that are going to be in these situations.
And it's the same thing again.
I tell this to businesses all the time,
have you done,
you know,
on a construction site,
have you done a drill?
If you have a mass casualty,
w do you know what,
you know where you're going to call in casualty evacuation?
Do you know we're getting into what the air,
air flight are a life flight numbers?
Does anyone have the life flight number here?
Because if someone gets hurt,
you need to make that call.
And do you know what station you're going to call,
what helicopter you're going to call?
Do you know where they're going to land?
Why would you not run those things?
And if those things unfold and you're not prepared for them,
you're going to fall apart.
And it's the same thing with these ethical and moral situations where if you
don't understand what they are and you don't understand what can go wrong,
you're gonna have,
you're gonna have a bad day.
And I felt he was,
but he didn't know what you brought up a little bit ago when you said there are
steps along the way that long before the crisis manifest itself.
There's that ability to recognize the tiny little steps that are leading there.
Now when you look at the tiny thing,
it looks tiny.
It doesn't look like a big deal.
That's no crisis that it's not a problem,
but he's that first step that's taking you down that path and it's a lot easier
to stop it orally than when crisis is on.
And so in that sense that does become a training that does become a thing of
like how do you recognize the steps,
how do you work on it and you know you are saying seeing so like even something
as magic.
I hate buddy too and sack on.
Take one second to breathe before you react.
Then seeing how you want to react is the same thing that applies to everything.
It applies to conversational.
When people are people you cared about,
maybe are getting you angry,
do you really want to respond right away or maybe take 30 seconds to take a
breath,
then decide how you want to respond.
You know,
and I think he's like to me is we are at as silly as that.
He's because you know clearly war and Pat I in are very far you'll need versus
I've seen so many ways but to me as being one of the seat,
if I think of the Archie,
it's I guess I got four class,
but I guess to me has been one of the most and forgiving mirrors that I added.
I ever had poutine front of me was seen our way or react under extreme stress
when you haven't slept for two days when somebody is throwing a fee,
so that's completely unjustified when and sad.
Then he's like,
yeah,
you have a little bit good reasons to be mad by really this is how you respond,
this is how you will react to a four year old kid was just being a 40 year old
key.
Then you get all emotional and do study island and suddenly like 10 Saquon seem
to me blow it up.
I see myself from the outside and I'm like,
um,
every scene that I despise in this moment to know that man right there,
that's the responding their way as all the reasons as all the,
I can see.
Why does it matter that you still don't do it?
You know?
And rather than just being like,
okay,
let's wait for myself,
I'm a horrible human being.
I discovered that.
He's like,
okay,
what can I do now to get the,
or next time you got real world world
training,
right?
Because now you recognize the situation and now you don't let it happen anymore.
Exactly.
You know,
I had,
I was talking to you guys earlier,
we,
I hit it,
my first deployment to Iraq,
we went and hit a target and,
and it sounds almost like,
you know,
like what you'd imagine in a movie.
We'd get handed a map then on the map and to be a city block and Baghdad and
there'd be a red x on one of the buildings and that's all I needed.
Oh you want me to go hit that red x?
Cool,
we'll go hit that red x.
And one night we went and hit,
you know,
the building with the red x on it.
And when we hit the target,
it was,
you know,
like the most normal family you could ever imagine.
And as we started talking to them and we had our interpreter get in there and
figure out,
hey,
do you know who this person is?
They're like,
yeah,
he lives two doors down.
Oh,
okay.
And so then I went back and eventually said to myself a question that if I
wasn't,
if I had more experience,
I would have asked this question from you.
I said,
Hey,
I've got a question.
Who put that red x on that building and why?
Right.
And as I pulled the string on it,
it,
you know,
it was one of those things where they had gotten some Intel,
which you know,
I won't talk about where it came from,
but it was,
it was intel that,
you know,
put it in that general vicinity and they like pick the center of the general
vicinity.
There's the senator of the genitals and either they will put the x and no follow
up.
And so I always taught that as something,
hey guys,
make sure you know who's giving you this intelligence.
And that's,
that's the case that happened to me.
Lie where the f the person on the,
no one,
no one at the platoon said,
hey,
whoa,
hold on a second.
Who's who's confirming that this is 100% VC in this village?
A hunch.
You're telling me this is 100% VC in this village.
That's what we're saying right now.
Who's talking,
who's saying that?
I want to talk to that person.
And that's another thing I talk about all the time is
okay,
you don't as a leader,
you don't want to be surrounded by yes men.
You don't want to be surrounded by yes.
Men.
And you know,
we're talking about the horrors of Vietnam War and I'm reading another book
right now and there's a platoon commander and his guys are going there.
They're rotating between three locations and two of the locations are not too
bad.
The other locations is a nightmare.
It's,
it's,
it's Vietnam war stereotypical.
It's booby traps,
snipers and indirect fire.
They never see the enemy.
They just never see the enemy.
And all they do is they go out there on patrol,
they get blown up,
they get shot,
they get mortared,
and they never see the enemy and the guy,
the guys are getting wounded or killed.
And
Yeah,
as you think about that,
yeah,
I would,
I would pray that if I was the company commander or the battalion commander,
that that platoon commander would come to me and say,
Hey Jocko,
this is stupid.
Let me tell you how many people we've lost any time,
any other of the platoons of lost.
And let me tell you what we've gotten out of it.
We've got nothing out of it and we,
we need to stop this or we need to find a better way to do it.
If you want to send us in there,
let us set up a strong point.
Let us set up a,
a bunkered position and we'll stay in.
We'll observe,
but us just walking around in there waiting to get blown up.
Makes no sense whatsoever.
Please,
let's do something else.
And as a leader you have to have the open mind to say,
okay,
I thank you,
I appreciate that feedback.
What are your suggestions?
You've been in the area of operations.
How do you recommend we do it?
And whenever I hear these stories of guys that get put in really terrible
situations in the military,
it,
it sickens my heart.
Because what you need is a culture inside any organization.
The military,
yes,
but any organization of people to raise their hands and say,
Hey,
wait a second,
this is stupid.
Hey,
wait a second.
Do I not see an American flag on that Indian reservation with a white piece flag
underneath it and wait,
wait,
hold on.
Stop.
Why wait,
wait,
stop.
And that takes moral courage.
It takes training and it takes a culture inside an organization to stop people
and question what they're doing.
And it takes a certain level of detachment that you were talking.
It absolutely takes detachment.
You know,
it's like,
uh,
you were saying about like dealing with a four year old or something.
Like when you're in the middle of it.
Yeah,
it's seems normal.
It seems like the way to behave.
And it's only when you step back and say,
well,
the,
you know,
uh,
one of the things about human beings are great strength I suppose is that we're
Supreme Lee,
adaptable creatures.
I was talking to a psychologist one time,
used to work for the State Department
and he would,
uh,
you worked in Africa for awhile and he talked about,
he was telling me some of the stuff that he would encounter whole villages,
um,
where every woman had been raped 10 times,
uh,
over the years where kids in this village had watched their parents killed.
Just horrifying stuff.
And my question to them at the time,
cause he was a psychologist,
uh,
was,
I mean,
how are are,
are these people not just completely blown out with Ptsd and everything else?
Like how are they functional at all given what we know about Ptsd and how it
does function under circumstances that are far less severe than that.
And that's what he said.
He said,
you'd be surprised.
Humans are very,
very adaptable into them.
This is their environment.
And that can work the other way too though,
you know,
that can work in the direction of,
uh,
in the new,
Ken Burns Vietnam documentary,
which is just,
I don't know if you've watched it yet,
the products,
I think the first two episodes,
so I'm one of the ones you're coming up on.
Uh,
the name of it is,
this is what we do.
And it starts out talking about this,
get new recruit and he shows up to this place and like the first thing he sees
when he gets to a,
the base he's at,
it's not a mask or anything like that,
but it's just sort of a,
you know,
a Vietnamese prisoner or,
or a captive,
uh,
being led along by,
you know,
a corporal or something and he's just being rough with them and kind of push
them along and doing stuff that clearly is outside of regulations.
And this new guy shows up and he's like,
Hey,
like you supposed to be doing that or whatever it is.
And the first thing he hears when he gets over there,
his kid,
this is Vietnam,
this is what we do.
And he said that their whole rest of the time that he was there when he saw
something he didn't like when he was doing things that he wasn't sure about,
he just repeated in his head,
this is Vietnam,
this is what we do,
this is what we do.
And after a while he didn't have to repeat it anymore.
After a while that was his environment.
And you know,
it reminds me,
I used to have these recurring dreams.
I probably shouldn't share this on the air,
but,
um,
I used to have these recurring dreams.
I still have them every once in a while.
Uh,
the details and the setting differ,
but um,
it'll be something like,
um,
the dream starts and I'm in like a helicopter say,
and I'm flying around like a city like la or wherever and I'm just shooting
people like grand theft auto.
It's just like a video game Tryna Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
And I'm going through and I'm doing all this.
Sometimes there's people down there,
I know my friends and stuff and it's just all,
it seems just like I'm in a video game.
And then the way the dream goes,
is it a certain point after a few minutes of this,
all of a sudden it hits me what I'm doing and I look around and I,
it's almost as if I wake up in the dream and I'm like,
oh my God,
like I'm killing all these people.
What,
what am I doing?
But at the time it was completely normal.
It seemed exactly like this is just what I should be doing or anything like
that.
And that's something that I think that is,
well it's why you told people stop looking down the barrel of your gun.
You know,
you got to step back and be able to get that distance so you can change your
frame.
And again,
with the proper training
and the proper education,
you will know as a leader that that behavior will escalate,
that behavior will escalate.
And if you allow it to happen,
it will continue to get worse.
And so it starts off,
and I've read all kinds of books about,
about Vietnam,
especially about Vietnam,
where it starts off,
it starts off with,
hey,
the villagers are,
we kind of know them,
everything's cool,
give them lollipops,
but then you know,
one of our guys dies and then what?
We're not getting lollipops.
As a matter of fact,
we're kicking the kids away and it,
it only escalates to their,
and it escalates to murder and it escalates.
Or I should say this,
it can escalate.
It doesn't automatically escalate because all it takes is someone to step in and
say,
Hey,
no,
that's across the line.
But you know what,
you want to slap a guy.
I get it,
I get it.
But that's the line.
Anything once,
you know,
one thing that we used to say,
and I used to tell my guys once the cuffs are on somebody,
so once we get somebody zip-tied it's over.
But you do what you gotta do to get a guy under control.
Once they're zip uptight,
it's done.
And now they're,
they're,
they're getting taken care of and you,
you treat them firm but fair.
That's it.
And so those lines,
you,
you have to draw them and you have to hold the line as a leader because things
start to escalate it,
you know,
says the thing that you were asking me about earlier about the,
the,
the Chechen war and the Russians against the Chechens and it's,
they didn't,
they didn't hold the line with the little things.
And that when you lose that discipline,
even up on the smaller things,
well eventually then you don't have the discipline on the bigger things.
Can you go overboard with that?
Yes,
you can.
I can hold the discipline so hard on the little things that no one listens to me
on the big things.
That's why leadership is hard because there's a dichotomy there that you have to
balance.
You can't be freaked out because you know,
you didn't,
you didn't blouse your boots when you were supposed to,
but at the same time,
if I start to let too many things slide well it will escalate.
And it seems like maybe with things like that,
a lot of people who were civilians,
they,
they laugh when they see in movies or
TV shows or something about how soldiers in combat are still expected to groom
themselves,
are still expected to take care of themselves and comport themselves in a
military way.
And what I tell them a lot of the times is,
and maybe you can confirm this because I don't really know what I'm talking
about,
but it is that,
uh,
you know,
my feeling on,
uh,
on,
on why that stuff is so important is that you can't have,
uh,
you know,
you can't have Iraq in the sectarian war in all the stuff,
the storm that's going on around them.
You can't have that become the environment to which they're adapting the
environment to which they need to be well adapted as the u s military.
That's their environment.
That's what they're focused on,
following these rules and behaving in this way.
And then when that's their environment,
they can go into these places and do their jobs if they get in there and start
reacting to what's going on around them.
Because I mean,
you,
you then you can tell a guy talking about going native.
Yeah.
Native,
you know,
once a apocalypse now,
right?
You can tell a guy once the cuffs are on.
Uh,
but you know,
if,
if I was talking to a family yesterday and this is the guy that just cut their
heads off,
well,
I mean,
you know,
you,
you can't have,
you can't put yourself in a situation because it does make sense to beat the
shit out of that guy.
It does make sense to put a bullet in his head when the cuffs are on,
like from a,
even from a moral standpoint in certain ways like that,
you can justify that,
you know?
Um,
and so that's why you can't be reacting to whatever it is it's going on.
And it sounds like that's kind of what you're saying.
Yeah.
And there's actually an interesting dichotomy there as well,
because
you,
you need to follow the rules,
right?
Because if I told,
if the three of us decided,
hey,
we're going to go on this village raid and we're all going to use our morals as
our guide,
well,
we have three different scenarios.
You're,
you just admitted that you'd be executing somebody that was already handcuffed,
uh,
who knows what you'd be doing.
You know,
I don't even want to know.
Right.
So,
so we were all over the map,
right?
Maybe you're,
maybe you're saying you're,
you're not even going,
I don't even want to handcuff anyone cause you think that's too offensive and
I'm somewhere in the middle.
Whatever the case may be,
we're all over the map.
So I would always tell the guys,
look,
you need to do what is legal,
what's legal?
But then the paradox of that is sometimes what you can get away with the legally
still isn't the right thing to do.
And that's again,
that's why there's a dichotomy between those two.
Between do I follow the rules exactly.
Or I mean,
you know,
look at,
look at me.
I look at Sand Creek that my boss told me to shoot.
This guy told me to shoot this three year old baby.
My boss told me to do that.
I am,
I should I be following orders?
Is there a threat that I don't know about?
You know,
these days,
you know,
I've heard a lot of stories now the guys that that took down Mozel right?
The,
the enemy was sending,
surrendering children to come and surrender to coalition forces.
And they would be strapped with,
uh,
id vests,
suicide vests,
and over and over and over again,
it was our US military,
you know,
especially our,
our explosive ordinance disposal folks and the,
that we're going in disarming these bombs on these kids.
But yeah,
how do you feel after you see two or three of those little kids get killed plus
two or three EOD guys get killed and now you're going to fight those guys and
they want to surrender.
That's a very challenging thing.
And if you don't maintain discipline,
it's a slippery slope.
And it's funny because we're saying two seats
said the same time,
which sound contradictory.
And yet that's life that on one end you need to have the super strict rules.
They are not going to bend under circumstances.
And on the other end,
your thing that you rightly point out too is the Fed.
That real leadership is also the ability to think on your feet.
And no two situations are alike.
So the rule following approach,
while he may save you from some of the worst abuses is not always necessarily
the right thing.
And there is also the time when we all lost follow the rules except when we
don't because that's the one time when it's correct and that ability to make the
right call at the right time,
that's what make you an makes that are already in our human being.
Just sort of in debates are popping off at the mouth today.
We,
we sort of take for granted that the whole,
um,
I was just following orders.
Question was settled at Nuremberg.
It was not settled at all.
That's an incredibly complicated question for just the reason you were
describing.
You know,
uh,
somebody who worked at a Nazi death camp,
um,
you know,
they didn't make 10,000 independent decisions to kill somebody.
Uh,
they made one decision that their own personal moral compass was going to get
outsourced to the state and that they were going to do their duty and follow
their orders.
They made that decision once and now,
once you've made that decision and you've outsourced your moral compass,
which again,
under most circumstances that might be the thing that keeps you from doing the
wrong thing now might be the thing that keeps me from executing that,
you know,
I'll kind of guy.
But when the institutions themselves start to get warped or if you're in,
even,
even if the institution is an individual unit or something,
you know,
uh,
it's,
I can't remember where I heard it,
but there's a,
some zoologist or somebody who pointed out to him that,
uh,
he had asked why zebras have black and white stripes when the grass is gold
colored in yellow and they don't blend into that at all.
Clearly Tigers can see that.
And he pointed out to him that that camouflage isn't to blend into the
environment.
That camouflage is to blend in with each other.
They blend with the herd.
And so the Tigers have a difficult time tracking down,
like in focusing on an individual.
And,
uh,
they,
oh,
they figured that out because they wanted to try to,
you know,
put ear clips on them or something to track these things around.
But they noticed every time they put something identifiable on one of them,
the Tigers would kill it.
And it was because now they had something to focus on.
And so,
and that's,
you know,
I'm not making a literal evolutionary comparison here,
but there's an interesting like,
just sort of analogy,
which is this instinct to blend in with the herd.
There's just their safety there.
There's a sense of security there and there's,
there's virtue in for fitting a certain amount of your personal judgment to the
group to which you have obligations.
That's a good thing under most circumstances.
You know what mean,
at least in a lot of circumstances,
you know,
that's what duty is.
That's what,
um,
you know,
just fulfilling your obligations to your people or you,
you,
your unit or something.
Like,
who are you?
Especially if you're an 18 year old kid who just got out of high school and
you're over there and you're in a situation where you've got,
you know,
like in me lie,
you've got officers,
you've got uh,
you know,
not just your immediate officer,
but it seems to be being reinforced by your captain above,
you know,
your company commander at the time,
and me lie,
there was a,
there was a major general in a helicopter observing,
buzzing around that place.
And so,
you know,
you're in a situation where you say to yourself like,
who am I to say that what's going on here is wrong?
It seems wrong to me because of what I learned from my Mama or whatever.
But you know what,
what does that mean?
I've got a captain,
I've got a lieutenant,
I've got my sergeant's,
I've got this major general in the air.
And you know,
maybe I'm wrong,
maybe this,
you know,
I just got here four months ago.
This was my,
this is a Charlie company's first major combat operation.
There's,
they really hadn't made contact,
direct combat with the enemy.
And this is the first time any of them have seen combat for the most part.
And I think it's uh,
um,
there's certainly a certain amount of weakness that's involved like you were
talking about.
But I also think there's a certain amount of moral confusion that happens and
that's,
there can't be that kind of confusion.
Like that is where leadership has got to take over.
Well,
I can add another layer of complexity to this.
Okay.
So,
so first of all,
I do think that the,
well Napoleon said,
if you execute an order that you know is wrong and what he was talking about it,
he's not talking about something.
And while he's talking about if I do something where a bunch of my men get
killed because the general said to do it and I do it,
I'm culpable.
So that's,
that's pretty clear that if your boss tells you to do something that you know is
gonna in Napoleon's case he was getting a bunch of your guys killed then,
then you say no.
And if you do it,
you're culpable for what happens.
You could say the same thing.
If if I get told to do something that's morally or ethically wrong and I do it
well,
guess what?
Then I'm responsible for that.
What?
What becomes a little bit complicated to me or adds another layer of complexity
is this.
If I'm going to sand creek and I'm with Chington and he or she havington and he
says,
Hey,
we're going to go there and we're going to execute this and we're,
we're,
we're going to kill these guys.
We're going to,
we're going to conduct a raid,
and I don't believe in it.
Okay?
So I say,
you know what?
I don't believe in it.
I don't think it's the right thing to do.
I think that we've made enough peace with them.
We've caused enough problems.
That's their land.
I'm not going,
okay,
so now you don't go because you didn't believe in the mission.
Well,
now who's out there conducting the mission?
Everyone that's going out there can come to conduct.
The mission is people that are compliant with what he's saying.
So you would be,
you would be morally a better person if you said,
okay,
I'm going to go ahead and do this because if I don't,
I know it's going to be someone that's totally compliant with Shervington and
I'd rather be there to at least spare some of the people,
which we know people did.
And so there's,
there's a little complex,
you know,
I talk about this in the business world too.
People say,
my boss told me to do this and,
and I,
I think it's a bad idea and I don't think we should do it.
Okay,
so are you going to get put off the project?
Are you going to get pulled to a different,
a different department where you no longer can take care cause you,
you listen too hard on my people,
I'm the,
I refuse to do this.
Okay,
that's fine.
You refuse to do this.
I'll put someone in there that won't refuse and you no longer can protect your
people and your people in a worse situation.
So you know,
there's organization is degraded the whole organization.
So you raise your hand,
you make your protest,
but sometimes you've got to say,
okay,
I've made my protest and I understand that you're still wanting me to do this.
And even though I think it's the wrong thing to do,
I'm going to proceed down the path because I'd rather me be able to mitigate as
much of this problem as I can.
Then have somebody that's just going to do,
do,
do this to the fullest extent that you would want them to do.
So there's another additional complexity there that it gets involved.
Absolutely.
Cause some time,
as you said,
just denying you're just making yourself feel better.
But the reality is that plan is going to go ahead.
You are the only thing that's standing in the way of that plan.
Going to the 100 percentile.
You can bring it down to 50 you know,
he's still gonna feel Aga.
You are still going to feel part of something you don't want to be part of.
But the only thing you do by refusing is patting yourself on the back and say,
I might all more I the guy.
He's like,
yeah,
but no,
because you know,
it's like the thing is you can use that power in that situation too for
something that is better than if you just,
uh,
look at herself in the mirror saying how great you are by not doing it.
And in fact,
that's what it was pitching fanatical about the Sun Creek story.
Yeah.
Silas soul,
you know,
they,
he's told right before you don't want to stay home.
Nobody's forcing you just stay home.
Don't be part of it and sold qure and some of those guys say,
no,
we want to be there.
We want to be there.
Cool.
Observed may be able to make the choice on this boat and uh,
and it makes a huge difference right there.
My feeling on it,
just sort of looking at it all from the outside is that especially in a
counterinsurgency war,
that without strict military discipline and strong leadership that abject
savagery is gravity will take you there.
That's where things will head on their own.
Unless you are supreme.
We focused on discipline and leadership and education and those kinds of things
that you don't have to,
you don't really have to ask the question,
how can this kind of thing happen?
The real question is how does this not happen all the time,
right?
How is it that American soldiers in Iraq and uh,
you know,
you go into Iraq and they're seeing,
uh,
maybe,
maybe husbands and fathers that they spoke to the previous day that they know
are innocent,
not part of the fighting.
And they see his wife beheaded and him with a power drill hole on the side of
his head.
How our American soldiers not going and executing reprisal attacks against these
people all the time.
How has it not just completely getting out of hand and like that to me is by far
the more interesting question.
I don't have to ask myself,
how is it that you know,
somebody went and shut up,
you know,
the,
that,
that the house of the person who did something like that.
That's an easy question to answer.
And,
and the,
the much more interesting one is how it doesn't happen all the time.
And it,
it seems like it's,
it has to be institutional.
It can't come down to like,
uh,
you know,
institutional culture,
right?
I'm relating it to their sense of personal identity and social identity with the
group that this is not who we are.
Um,
that if I do this,
it's not going to win me any,
uh,
any Kudos from my teammates or anything like that.
There you're going to look at that as a betrayal because I'm bringing dishonor
upon us because this is not what we're about.
And they have to be able to look at it that way.
And if they don't know that,
if they don't know that,
uh,
by doing something like that,
they're going to,
uh,
you know,
they want to blend in with the group.
They want to be accepted by the group.
They want to be looked at as somebody that can be relied on.
And that has to mean following the rules and doing the right thing.
Yeah.
Well did Danielle,
you poured it,
pointed this out earlier you,
you said,
well this seems like it's just the communications aspect is so important and
that's 100% right.
So as we all know,
the,
the
strategy in the Vietnam War for America was to kill more of them.
Then they data vos and drop more bombs on them and eventually they'll just break
just a war of attrition.
And,
and so the,
the strategy was get rack up as many kill,
count as high kill count as you possibly can.
So that's the messaging,
that's the messaging.
So when that's the messaging,
that's the messaging in,
in Iraq they were very clear about,
hey,
we're here too.
We're,
we're not an occupying force.
We're here to liberate these people were here to secure the populous and make
sure that they can have a free country.
That's the messaging.
So does that messaging always make it down to the front lines,
know that's why we do have incidents where,
you know,
bad,
horrible things happen.
Absolutely.
But it is about the messaging and it is about everyone understanding why they're
doing what they're doing,
what their mission is,
what is what is right and what is wrong.
And you can be educated on that legally,
hey,
you're not allowed to do this.
You can do that,
but you can't do this.
And then the other point that you made,
which is,
well,
you said you've got to be able to manage people in a time of crisis as a leader,
but more important.
And you,
you actually,
why you actually asked a really complicated question and then answered it
yourself.
And you did that like three times and that one sphere of conversation that you
had with yourself.
Yeah,
yeah.
Is,
is you said,
you know,
you gotta be able to manage people in these pressure situations and then you
added that.
But what you really need is culture.
And you're right because you're not going to be there.
The leader is not,
I wasn't with my,
all my elements on the battlefield all the time.
They were out there all the time without me all the time without me.
They were the ones that had to understand what they could and what they couldn't
do.
They were the ones that had to make those hard decisions.
They weren't calling my snipers,
didn't call back to me and say,
Hey Jocko,
I see this with this guy.
They didn't even ask their platoon commanders that they didn't ask anyone.
They knew what the rules of engagement,
where they knew what our strategy was.
They understood.
And one of the things that I told them,
you know,
speaking of rules of engagement,
so our rules of engagement was,
you know,
several page legal document written by some lawyers in Washington DC or
wherever.
And you know,
I've got kids in my platoon that are 20 2122 years old,
you know,
high school graduate and they came in the seal teams like I did by the way.
And so they're looking at a legal document like that does,
it doesn't mean anything to them.
You know,
my rules of engagement for them was it very simple.
Make sure that people,
you're killing our bad.
You make sure the people you're killing her bat and why.
And then I explained to them why that was important.
And the reason why that was important was because the day that some civilians
brought a headless body that it had taken a 300 win mag round to the head and
their head was gone and they said,
this was our a mom,
or this was our school teacher,
or this was our neighborhood doctor,
and one of your snipers killed them and they would figure it out.
It was us.
First of all,
our operations would get shutdown.
So selfishly,
we don't want to get our operations shutdown,
but more important than the selfish reason.
If that happened,
we would leave all the soldiers and marines that we were working with on a daily
basis that we are providing Overwatch for.
We've leave them without the support that we had committed to give them because
we weren't allowed to operate anymore because we weren't being discriminatory
enough with our fire.
So the culture is so important.
People understanding why they're doing what they're doing is so important.
And if you don't get that messaging into your point,
DNA,
Daniella,
if you don't get the communication correct,
then you're going to end up in a world of hurt
and to point you just made,
make sure the people you key or bad,
he's such shit.
I think about a day or so few awards,
right?
You say teen lake,
very,
very few words and yet he's so centered because you look at,
not all the curry core me lie,
but look at even like half of the,
you know when the Nazi seeing invade the Soviet Union and then when the Red Army
does the counter and they start invading Germany,
both armies do horrible seeings to one another.
Cv Leon.
And the idea is,
well the Nazis did to our people.
So we did it today.
Our swell that Ma'am that you are shooting in the head at it.
She had nothing to do with what happened to your people.
She's,
she's not the Nazi soldier would eat it.
She's not the bad one just because she's from the same nation.
Are you kidding me?
That's not,
that doesn't make her a bad person.
And I think that's part of the problem.
We group identity that.
So then that's why I stayed with types are dangerous because you start grouping
individuals into this mental category you may have of like those guys are bad,
that individual,
I'll only share some physical characteristic with the other one they share maybe
the or even are related,
but they are not the same person.
You know they are date,
I haven't made the same choices.
They haven't committed the same action.
So the fact that you three told the Cheyenne the same or you decided to retool
the Vietnamese the same or the Germans?
The same oral.
The Russians,
that's where every single is wrong because he are not making sure that the
person you're hurting is the bad one is not the one.
There's no revenge dare.
They are not the same people.
And so and yet it happens over and over again.
Where people fall into this idea of group mentality is,
well I couldn't catch that guy back.
He's one of the or group is I know man,
there are individuals that are involved that are not,
there's no collective guilt off.
It's kind of the same reason why,
for example,
federal reasons strike as I saw all fall in every possible way because you're
now going against the guide.
I have a grievance against.
You're going against the guy from the same nation.
It's like that has nothing to do with one another.
You know,
they're,
I feel like sometimes group identity,
it's one of those double edged swords,
right?
Because on one hand there's a side of it that we mentioned earlier.
Maybe your loyalty to your group and not wanting to bring dishonor upon them if
that's the culture is what keeps you from putting a bullet in the head of the
guy you just cuffed.
Um,
you might be able to appeal to a,
um,
you know,
you can say to people,
hey,
we're Americans and this is not how we behave and you're appealing to their
group identity there,
you know,
and uh,
that
nobody's saying it's a double edge sword.
That is a case in which you are using group identities for as the good guys.
And,
and granted,
yeah,
it may not be that every single one from [inaudible] three really feed that idea
by you're putting a nice ideal and they are encouraging people to live up to it.
That's all the IDD furnace from.
While it's similar in dynamics too damned bad guys and flagging everyone into
dad group,
where do you know that that person really fit that stereotype at the Ui of
[inaudible]?
How did you make clear to your men,
uh,
when you said,
you know,
make sure the people you're killing or bad that they understood what was meant
by that.
It is,
well there's first of all there,
there are specifics and the rules of engagement and one of them is called clear
hostile intent,
hostile actor,
which means this person has to be doing something actively that's gonna cause it
cause a negative impact.
Now
you can tell which people are bad.
You can tell when they're starting to do something that's a hostile act or
hostile intent.
You can tell.
And these guys,
you know,
my guys would,
they,
they knew,
they would err on the side of like,
I'm going to make sure that this person is doing something bad.
But you know,
we had some decent,
uh,
arguments about the rules of engagement.
I had some decent arguments about the rules of engagement up the chain of
command because the rules of engagement were applying to all of Iraq and Ramadi
was not like the rest of Iraq at this time in 2006.
And you know,
if you've got someone that is,
for instance,
observing a location with binoculars,
right?
If you're observing,
if you're in Baghdad and you're look looking at a location with binoculars,
you're gathering intelligence,
which is,
which,
which could be considered,
which is not considered a hostile act.
It's,
it's,
it's the intelligence gathering.
You might suspect the person being bad,
but there's,
there's no way to prove that in Ramadi.
If you saw somebody that was looking with binoculars at friendly forces,
they weren't gathering intelligence,
they were absolutely coordinating attack and attack.
And that is a group that is a big difference because that is a hostile act.
And it's damn sure hostile intent.
And so,
you know,
those are the kinds of things that I would discuss up the chain of command and
we would provide them the resources.
You know,
it's,
I talk a lot about playing the game,
right?
Like if my boss tells me to do something,
I'm going to play the game.
I'm going to try and do it.
And,
and,
and occasionally I'll get the question of like,
well,
what if you get told to do something that you really don't want to do?
What if you've got told to do something that you didn't,
that you were posed to,
right?
What if you got the order to go to the me Lai massacre and you got the order?
Well,
yeah,
it's,
I know I'd say no.
And first of all,
that doesn't happen the closest,
the closest example I have to that happening was for me in Ramadi,
we had been told that we had to take a certain number of Iraqi soldiers with us
on every operation we conducted because we were trying to turn the war over to
them.
And so they needed to get out there.
And do operations,
and they were telling us they were putting this,
this rule all over every American unit and Iraq.
You needed to have an Iraqi face on every operation.
So what did the Americans do?
What did,
what did the American units do?
What they did was they say,
okay,
yeah,
we're going to take our platoon of 40 guys and we're going to take to Iraqis
with us,
and there's your Iraqi face.
Well,
that doesn't move the wharf forward.
They were obeying the rules.
So the,
the senior leadership figured this out and said,
no,
you guys are playing games.
Here's the new rule for every,
and I forget what the number was.
They made a ratio for every seven Americans that you have,
or for every one American,
you'd have to have,
you have,
you have to have seven Iraqi's are,
there were some numbers,
some ratio,
and in Ramadi,
some of the units of Iraqis that we were working with only had 18 guys or 17
guys.
And so that would have been me sending my guys in the field with two or three
seals only,
which sending,
if you've got a,
if you're going to go into a bad area and you're going to,
who are you going to send?
Because you want to have a radio man,
you want to have a medic,
you want to have a guy that can call for fires.
You want to have a leader and you want to have a couple heavy heavy weapons
guys,
that's,
that's six or seven guys right there.
Minimum,
right?
And so when the chain of command told me,
hey,
you got to do this ratio,
I looked at the ratio and the,
and I said,
hey guys,
uh,
in Ramadi,
that's,
that's not a good idea and here's why.
I'm not going to send my guys in the field without a corpsman or without a radio
man,
without a Jay Tac or without a machine gunner.
I'm not,
I'm not going to do that.
And you know what they said?
They said,
that makes sense.
Chocolate,
you proceed.
Like if you articulate yourself correctly,
then you can get your point across.
Now head,
they said to me,
hey,
listen,
no,
you're only allowed to do this.
Well then I would have objected further up the chain of command and I would not
have put my guys at risk to do something that didn't make sense.
I'm not going to do it.
Um,
and,
and again,
that's what I always encourage military people,
but not as military people,
business people.
If you're the CEO of a company and you've given some directive that you don't
understand the full depth of the directive that you've given and your front line
somebody,
somebody in your front lines realizes that's going to have a hugely negative
impact on your company.
Do you want them just to follow orders?
You absolutely don't want them to followers.
You want them to raise their hand and say,
hey boss,
this doesn't make sense.
And Athenia you said about,
yeah,
you don't want to surround yourself with yes men,
which makes perfect sense.
Then again,
eats.
It's one of the sinks where you really need to have work on yourself because the
reality is that most people have an ego.
Most people don't like to be told,
hey boss,
sorry about that doesn't sound right.
He's like,
well do you mean,
you know there's that reaction is like standing in their pride,
which of course that were old bad decision making started going,
but he's a very normal reaction.
You know what I mean?
He's like most people have to one degree or another and ego and his speech.
A leaf like your guy maybe phrase it.
Maybe they are right,
right.
The makeup falling toward,
they are pointing to something in your plan and doesn't work.
But the phrase it in a way that's kind of blonde.
So a,
you don't like being watched.
The,
you don't like the tone by that point,
even though their content is perfectly correct,
you're not eating it because he's like,
you have a better,
I don't like you first.
They crazy size we can.
Then you are going about it with that tone.
The guy is just saying seeings plainly out they are.
Maybe it's not,
it doesn't have a bad tone is just not Cogley knew.
Wayne likes lowly Jane saying,
Hey,
let's see this way.
And,
and you know what a guy in that,
cause I get the,
I get that kind of question all the time with all the companies we work with.
I've got this guy and my,
my boss has a big ego and I can't correct him because he just,
he just gets a fee.
Well first of all,
when you just like you said,
if you've got a big ego and I tell you that your plan is wrong,
I'm attacking a four to five position and you're only going to bolster your
position stronger.
And so don't attack that position instead of simple technique that you can use
is say,
hey boss,
I'm really not sure why we're using this approach.
Could you explain this to me?
Because I want to make sure that I really understand what it is you want me to
do.
And it seems like if I do this right here,
it's going to cause this reaction and I don't want,
I know you don't want that to happen,
so could you just give me a hand and fully understanding what your plan is?
And that way you're,
you're,
you're kind of massaging their ego a little bit and it opens their mind and
that's all you have to do is open up their ears.
That's the goal is just to open their ears a little bit so that you can start to
have a conversation with them and so that they can get going back to the whole
topic of today so that they can see you as a human being with a,
with an idea or an opinion that actually matters as opposed to seeing you as
someone that's attacking their ego.
And that ego thing.
I mean,
if you think about the wars that have been,
you know,
we always talk about the wars that are caused by religion,
but the wars that are caused by ego or are also pretty severe.
And a lot of these incidents that we talk about,
these retaliatory incidences,
well,
who's going to be the first person to say,
you attacked my tribe and I'm going to let it slide.
But that's,
that's,
that's a tough person.
That's a hard position to be in.
You're seen as weak.
You're seen as you,
you know,
vulnerable.
You're seen as someone that can be pushed around.
So there's,
that's a very delicate game that you have to play and that causes problems in
that that ends up,
that's a game that's so hard to play.
In fact that most people,
or many people across the span of time have said,
no,
I'm not going to say that they did.
They drew blood.
We're going to draw more.
Yeah.
Blood.
Yup.
And it
goes to what you were saying a second ago to your people have to know that
you're going to ask those questions of your leadership and that you're doing
that work because they got to trust you.
You know,
that way when Jocko comes to him and says,
hey guys,
I know this is going to sound a little bit weird,
but here's what we're doing and here's who you're bringing with you and this is
what we're doing.
They know that if you're telling them to do it,
it's gotta be done.
That every discussion has been had that every angle has been looked at,
that you've run it up the chain of command and registered your objections if
they're there,
but they know that Jocko is not going to send us out to do something like this
unless it simply has to be done.
And I get asked this question a lot,
well,
what do I do if one of my subordinates has a question about the way I've planned
something and I don't have a good answer?
What do I do?
Then I say,
well,
what you do then is you listen to them.
You actually listened to what they're saying because if,
if,
if I've told you to do something and you've then responded with some reason why
we shouldn't do that thing and I can't explain away your reason,
then probably I'm wrong.
And and as a leader,
this is another thing where our ego plays a role as a leader.
Our Ego says,
well,
if I admit that I'm wrong to the troops,
they're going to think I'm up there going to think I don't know what I'm doing.
The opposite is actually true.
If I was in charge of youtube and I presented you with a plan and you guys came
back and today that plan's not smart and I said,
shut up and do it the way I told you you don't respect me more.
You respect me less.
And if if I came to you two with a plan and said,
hey guys,
here's the way we're going to execute this.
And you say,
Hey,
that's not a good idea.
We should do it a different way.
And I say,
okay,
well what do you recommend?
And we come together with a collaborative plan.
You don't think less of me as a leader.
As a matter of fact,
you think more of me as a leader,
you think that I'm a humble guy that will listen and take input.
And by the way,
bonuses,
you all now have real true ownership of the plan and we all feel good about it.
And when you guys go on the field,
you execute it to the utmost of your ability because it's something that you
own.
It's amazing how everything you're saying is,
it's as if you took a list of all the traits of Lieutenant Calley at me lie and
literally just said,
do the opposite of all these things.
He was a guy who couldn't take criticism from his men,
100% who asserted a,
you know,
who,
who pulled rank anytime anything like that happened.
Uh,
who was a complete transparent yes man to his captain above him who was just
never ask any questions.
I mean,
just right down the line.
And as a result,
his men had no trust in him so that when they got into a situation that was
chaotic,
they felt like they were standing out on the corner by themselves in a country
they didn't understand with nobody looking out for them.
I don't want to say this in a way that makes it sound like I'm trying to justify
anything they did,
of course not.
But you put men in a situation where they feel like they're in complete chaos
and they happen to have automatic weapons in their hands.
Well,
if I find myself in a situation where I'm completely overwhelmed by chaos,
that automatic weapons probably going to start to look like the best tool I have
for structuring my environment.
Yeah,
there's a,
and,
and obviously this went way beyond that.
The,
uh,
years ago,
I forget how many years ago there was a shooting in New York City,
uh,
I think it was 38 rounds were fired at uh,
maybe a homeless person and unarmed person.
I forget the situation,
but there's a lot of people that just couldn't believe that all these,
all these police officers shot at this unarmed individual,
horrible situation.
And again,
I always have always will say this,
like whenever I talk about bad police shootings,
I been on ride alongs with cops.
I've done hits with cops.
It's a freaking hard job.
And,
and I'm not a guy that like,
I've done that a couple times here and there,
but go out on that beat every day and deal with those scumbags of the world
every single day.
And you're going to have,
it's going to be,
it's the freedom.
It's one of the hardest jobs in the world.
That situation people to,
how the hell did that happen?
Well there's,
there's a lot of tension in a situation that emotions are high,
people are screaming,
we're not trained well.
Everyone is sitting there with their slack out the trigger and when that first
bang happens,
it's a,
it's a chain reaction.
That's one of,
one of the situations that,
you know,
I would see with my guys that was beautiful in Ramadi was they wouldn't do that
if,
if one of the snipers took a pointed shot at someone,
they would take the point of shot and the others would hold fire,
check fire until,
you know,
the,
the situation either evolved or,
or deescalated.
But the,
the army was always quite impressed with the fact that we would take really
surgical shots at bad guys and there wouldn't be,
you know,
massive amounts of collateral damage.
Um,
again,
sometimes it's unavoidable,
but
maybe you can talk a little bit about that.
Cause I think that's one thing that gets really lost on a lot of people saying.
I think there's a lot of propaganda that helps it get lost.
You know,
there's no question that there's been an evolution and,
um,
our values and our relationship to these kinds of things over the years.
So you go back to something like San Creek,
1864,
uh,
there might not have been a whole lot of people shedding too many tears over
what happened.
You get up to me lie and you know,
there's some controversy and there's some,
you know,
there's a cover up,
all those kinds of things,
but once it comes out and it's laid bare and the evidence is clear,
things had changed from 1864,
and that,
that incident and a few,
you know,
other incidents that were going on,
it made it out.
Or a few pictures that came out,
it turned people against the war.
They decided that this is not worth putting our men in a situation where we're
going to be doing things like this.
This is not worth it.
And you get up to today,
uh,
in the Iraq war,
something like Abu Ghraib,
which is an unacceptable situation,
but we're talking about prisoner abuse.
That doesn't,
uh,
th th that wouldn't cause the people who were working that prison five years
before that the Iraqis who worked for [inaudible] that wouldn't even,
you know,
they,
they wouldn't even make it through their filter.
Right.
So,
I mean,
what,
what was going on there with the American soldiers,
it was,
it was not okay,
but it wasn't walking into a village and mastering 500 people.
It wasn't,
uh,
you know,
brutal torture in the same way that we would think of what was going on before
we took control of that prison.
And yet our response to that in the military's response to it once it came out
was pretty dramatic.
I mean,
it was theirs and it was quick.
It didn't,
there was not as much of a delay as soon as it comes out.
There's,
so there's a clear shift that's going on there.
If,
if even primarily from the standpoint of it's just,
it's a breach and discipline,
that's not how you behave.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and one of the things that I'd talk about with my guys is because you got to
frame this right because you know,
you mentioned earlier that if you had to dealt with this person that had cut the
heads off of the three year old girl yesterday and now you,
you had him cuffed and you knew it was him,
that guy deserves a bullet,
right?
I,
Hey,
I agree with you.
That guy deserves a bullet.
The,
the problem is,
well number one,
it's a breakdown in discipline,
but to me more important and what I would tell my guys is if we behave that way,
we have a significant chance of strategically negatively impacting our war
effort.
So I get that you want to kill these bad guys,
but more important than us killing these bad guys is us in winning this war.
And so if we run around doing dumb things,
we're going to have a negative strategic impact on the,
and that was actually always the biggest worry as a leader is you don't want to
have some,
something happened where you know,
you,
you drop a bomb on the wrong area or you know,
in a bunch of civilians get killed or you know,
you,
you don't want to have that thing happen.
That's a real,
and the effort and lengths that American forces go to to prevent civilian
casualties is,
it's incredible.
I don't think most people have any idea.
No,
they don't.
They don't works.
And I think that's why we're the coolest things about creatine ascertain
mythology that people would want to live up to the first time you say it,
he may not be through,
he may be a wishful thinking that you hired those people and you're not quite
there.
But as people keep repeating eighth and your aunt again and again,
we'd,
the fact that your behavior doesn't match your ideas more and more people we
keep working on trying to actually build that thing.
They don't want to feel that like hypocrites.
They actually want to live up to that idea.
And that's one of the sinks were why is sometimes people get turned off by when
you have these high minded id I'll and this very poor behavior.
Or they're like,
oh look at that Hippocrates,
they,
Sadie's seeing Sunday Dominico well sometime when you say it long enough,
people actually do want to live up to it and they do change their behavior.
So while the theory may not match the practice,
when you start,
if you keep at it long enough,
the practice may try to inch closer to mention that theory ideals.
And that's not a bad thing.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
you can take it
to,
uh,
political context,
right.
When people can point back at the United States say before the 1960s and before
the civil war and point to the Constitution and declaration of independence in
these high minded ideas,
and people love to be the cynical one that says,
oh yeah,
yeah,
but slavery and of course,
but this and,
but that,
and yeah,
totally,
totally true.
But the,
the,
the conclusion to draw from that is not that,
uh,
the ideals don't matter or that they're just on paper.
The fact that those ideals were there was what allowed the civil rights movement
to eventually apps come into being.
That's what,
you know,
gave us the room.
In fact,
you could even say that the thing we're talking about,
the same thing,
uh,
that gap between ideal and reality.
One Way to talk about that is hypocrisy.
But at the same time,
that gap,
that opening is,
that's the opening where people realize that and say there is a gap between our
professed ideals and,
and it makes room for that of positive change.
Right?
I mean,
you can go back,
uh,
there was,
the Mongols were never ever going to give up slavery because their moral system
didn't have room for that.
Yeah.
And so if you could go up to them and say,
well,
how dare you enslave these people and they're not going to get defensive,
they're going to look at you like you're crazy because there's no room for that,
you know,
for that gap,
that idea doesn't even exist.
Right.
Right?
And so the ideal is matter.
And when,
uh,
when,
when they're broken,
um,
you know,
again,
I think that there's a motivation on the part of a lot of people who are,
who were more cynical than they should be,
a given the country that they're fortunate enough to live in.
You know,
um,
this is something that you get from going overseas to a lot of places.
It's something certainly that I got from spending so much time in Africa,
in the Middle East for work is boy,
you come back after the first trip to over to those places and you realize you
want to kiss the ground when you get off that airplane and you want to go around
and just hug everybody.
You see,
because you are so fortunate to live in a place where things that we absolutely
take for granted over here are miracles.
And,
um,
you know,
I,
I think,
uh,
one of the things I did really didn't want to do,
um,
when I was talking about me lying that episode,
I stayed very focused on the,
uh,
the incident itself,
sort of.
Um,
because I,
you don't want to,
you don't want to be making excuses for something like that and you don't want
to make it seem like you're trying to go look gloss over and atrocity.
Um,
but,
but you don't want to,
uh,
give fuel to that idea that like this is,
this speaks to like a larger problem in our society because I just don't believe
that it's
a dance,
right?
If you start pushing the button too much in the direction of making apologies
for where laughter,
all we are good guys and there are a few exceptions by Luke.
We are,
we stand for freedom and democracy.
He's like,
yeah,
maybe,
but let's not be so quick about sweeping under the rug.
All the bad stuff.
Let's look at it.
The guys,
we instead push on the button of,
Hey,
look at all the bad stuff.
That means that all these ideas are crap and it's not real and it's solely
Parker's.
He's like,
Whoa,
slow down on a second.
Yeah,
you've got a couple of points where you are right by are also missing the boat.
It's like,
it's almost like,
and that happens in most discussion,
like in most situations,
you rarely have somebody with 100% wrong,
is that they take a partial truths and they take it too far and they lose
perspective of the other side of the equation.
People don't understand like American soldiers were killed and maimed,
uh,
in situations that absolutely could have been avoided if we disregarded our
rules of engagement.
And if we made,
like,
we made conscious decisions to put ourselves at risk when we did not have to
because we were trying to be sensitive to the environment and to the people that
were.
And I don't think enough people recognize the historical anomaly that that is.
I mean,
that is just a,
you can't,
for thousands of years of human history that is just completely unthinkable.
You couldn't imagine something like that.
And the extent to which we go,
I mean Jocko has talked about this before on his show,
the extent to which we go to try to make sure that the people,
you know,
the targets that we're,
that we're dealing with our targets.
Um,
I think if more civilians had,
uh,
had,
an idea of that people would feel a lot different about,
about what we do over there.
You know,
it doesn't mean that when something happens like ob of grave,
they're not going to react against that,
but they're going to react against it from a place of,
hey,
we're,
we're a good country.
That shit is not going to fly.
All right?
That's not what,
you're not going to represent us that way.
And that's fine.
That's a healthy way to respond to something like that.
Um,
but you know,
again,
it was a political situation or whatever else is going on.
Like,
you know,
people have more of a knee jerk reaction to those things that you're talking
about it,
so you can get that sense.
It goes back to that,
uh,
Dan Carlin approach to saying so,
right?
That ability to look at sinks one way and just when you're getting comfortable
with Dako inclusions to say,
yes,
maybe that is the conclusion we take,
but it's not that easy.
There's also a 20% from the other side.
It's not really wrong.
Then you food including that and,
and that keeps you thinking on your toes.
You don't become dogmatic.
You don't become thinking purely black and white terms.
You all the way staff to have that nuance approach,
which,
and that's the problem.
That's the other pirate jokes.
He's,
most people have take an alliance to mean weakness,
then you can't make up your mind.
You are too wishy washy.
You are is not black.
He an off why two somewhere in there is like mill.
That's also a weakness is the ability to look at things both ways and also make
a decision that's where can we can seen as when it's available.
And I think he's funny because so many of the things that joker brings up are so
about really the kind of human being that you want to become.
You know about self perfection really.
Cause that's what it boils down to,
which is Dan,
what makes you a great leader because there's no good athlete or without
somebody was working on themselves a lot and you know when you better get down
to depending suppose nothing sounds like it's that hard,
right?
He's all like,
okay,
of course.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
So that completely and yet it's one of the Sikhs were,
while the theory may not be that hard,
the practices and the Atlanta team,
you have to be at it every single day or it's so easy.
It was leap.
There's,
there's a great line,
I need to doubt a change that I was bad,
surely to their road we're driving down.
There's,
there's the line at say may way is very easy to understand and very easy to
practice,
but nobody understand it at nobody trap.
And I love it because in tod,
yes,
it's not that bad.
It's fairly straightforward and yet there are so many steps along the way where
it's easy to go their own path that is like,
yeah,
the theory is easy.
The practice cs,
you need to put in the work that each of those steps matters so much to,
because you know,
Jocko was talking about escalation in those situations.
The um,
the book about the war in Chechnya,
you talked about,
I think the line,
I hadn't read the book until I heard your podcast on it and it just,
it's one of those things that when you hear it,
it's so obvious.
But if you were to just step back from the context,
a little bit kind of seems ridiculous is which is that the savagery started when
people stop shaving,
when soldiers stopped shaving.
And I think part of the reason for something like that is,
uh,
once it is,
it's like the escalation.
It's like a ratchet.
Once you stopped shaving,
well now you're a unit that doesn't shave anymore.
Okay,
whatever.
Well,
what that means is if you're a unit that lacks discipline,
well now your lack of discipline is not going to manifest,
is not shaving.
You already don't shave.
That's normal.
That's totally normal.
So now your lack of discipline is going to get to the next thing.
Now I'm not cleaning my weapons properly.
And then pretty soon you're a unit that doesn't shave and doesn't clean your
weapons properly.
And that doesn't even seem like a lack of discipline anymore.
That just seems like daily life and now your lack of discipline or whatever it
is,
it's going to go up to the next spot and it can happen with,
you know,
it can happen with just brutality and savagery and things like that as well.
We're now,
this kind of thing is just normal.
So if I'm angry,
uh,
and it's totally normal for us to be able to smack these prisoners in the face,
but now I'm really pissed I'm not going to smack them in the face.
I smack them in the face anyway,
you know?
So I'm going to show my anger now by stepping it up and man,
well,
okay,
if that's,
if that slides and the leadership doesn't step in,
well now that's normal.
You know,
we're,
you know,
we don't just smack soldiers,
we punched and kicked soldiers that once,
that's the baseline,
it ratchets up to that point.
Well,
it's going to escalate from there because you know,
that's kind of where it goes.
And that's why catching those things right at the beginning and letting people
know that,
you know,
all of these things matter.
I mean that's probably the life lesson.
A lot of the stuff you even talk about it,
everything matters.
It all matters.
Yeah.
And not,
it takes some time.
Like I didn't,
I didn't realize this when I was a 20 year old seal or a 25 year olds seal.
You know,
I kind of started getting the indications and,
and that's why again,
you know,
I talk about training and leadership because that's what this stuff is,
putting somebody into a moral dilemma
with no training is like putting someone onto the Jujitsu Mat with no training.
They're just going to get destroyed.
Whatever's gonna happen is gonna happen and they have no control over it.
And you know,
you got to think about these things.
You've got to think deeply about these things so that you have some sort of an
anchor that's grounded,
that won't get ripped out at the first person that says,
hey shoot,
that three year old baby you want,
you need to be grounded and have thought about these things in a deeper way.
And,
and you know what you said about people swaying one way or the other.
You're right and people actually want to be led and they want to be led even
more.
So when there is a pressure situation going on,
when there's something that you're not used to or that people aren't used to,
some kind of structure,
some kind of stress or pressure,
if you can step up and lead at that moment,
people are looking for,
they're looking for a leader and that was it.
I remember you were talking about one of the guys and be lie the six foot three
guy and he's a natural leader,
right?
He's a natural leader that people kind of followed in what he started going
sideways and it started just getting completely savage and brutal people just
kind of,
okay,
you know,
he's the guy,
like,
okay,
that guy's stepping up and,
and that's,
and,
and there was no one on the other end of the spectrum to say,
Hey,
no,
we're not doing that.
Stop.
And that's the biggest lesson from that situation actually from both the
situations.
And,
you know,
people talk about is how can the leader be responsible if they're not there?
You know?
Yes.
The leader's responsible,
whether they're,
the way they trained,
the people,
the way they educated,
the way they communicated,
the culture that they sat with those people,
they're responsible.
And certainly these leaders were absolutely responsible in these scenarios.
I guess before we are out,
one last thing I want to ask you is these days,
um,
you say you work a lot with businesses.
You clearly are,
you know,
you're working primarily on the concept of leadership and out teach people a
better tools to handle it.
How do you go about it?
What's your,
what's easy?
But I'm already like in business oriented approach now with major businesses
that are,
yeah,
we'll go in and do an assessment and figure out where the friction points are.
Figure out where they're having problems and,
and then we solve the problems that they're having through leadership.
And that's every single problem in every single organization is a leadership
problem.
All of them,
whether it's your P and L's upside down,
whether it's your processes aren't,
aren't working correctly,
whether you've got the wrong people in the wrong positions,
it doesn't matter what the problems are going to get solved through leadership
and leadership alone.
And that's why we,
that's why we're doing well because if you've got a,
if you've got a p and l,
it's upside down.
You've got leaders that aren't paying attention to their expenditures and their
income,
right?
If you've got processes that aren't working,
you've got leaders that are in charge of those processes that are allowing them
to continue to exist without refinement.
If you've got people that are in positions that shouldn't be in those positions,
you've got leaders that are allowing them to be in those positions without
either being coached and mentored and trained so that they can lead or removed
from those positions and you can go right down the list with any problem that
any organization is having.
There's a leadership solution to that problem and that's what we
do.
It seems to me like as definitely the thing I'm going to take away from the most
and listen you talk about this stuff is one of the things that struck me as I
came in with a lot of questions in mind.
I wanted to talk to you about like that I started out with,
right you,
you've got your guys,
you're going into a horrible situation and there's these horrible things going
on.
How do you restrain your guys from going and retaliating in these terrible ways
and your response and the look on your face and everything to it?
It actually like kind of threw me off a little bit.
It wasn't what I,
what I was expecting because your,
your answer to that really was,
dude,
if I have gotten to the point where we're there in Iraq and there was a guy with
handcuffs and I have to figure out how to restrain my guys from doing something
I failed a long time ago.
You cause you took it as almost like Ah,
well you know,
you deal with it.
That was taken care of.
We,
how do we stop them?
We stopped him in training,
we stopped at in bootcamp,
we stopped to make buds.
We stopped them in turn all the way up to here.
And I don't want to make that,
I don't want to,
I don't want to make that,
I don't want to make light of that cause that,
that is a hard situation.
And when you lose guys in a unit of 35 guys and you got guys that are wounded
and killed,
there is absolutely,
uh,
there is an absolute fire that you have to control because we know who's doing
it.
We can find them,
we can get out there and get and get after them.
And so we,
we do have to keep ourselves in check.
We do,
I mean we had many conversations of hey,
remember why we're here.
Remember who we represent.
Remember that if we get out of line,
we won't even be allowed to do what we do anymore.
Oh,
so,
so don't take it the wrong way.
That in any unit,
any unit,
you lose people,
you lose your friends,
you lose your brothers.
That is an emotional,
it's an emotional thing and you're in an emotional situation already and you
have access,
direct access to unleash your emotions if you are allowed to.
And Yeah,
the,
you know,
with the platoon commanders that worked for me with,
I mean those guys,
you know,
Lafe who wrote the book with me,
I mean he absolutely had to,
had to sit as guys down and explained to them,
hey,
let's remember why we're here.
Let's remember that we could go to jail if we do the wrong thing.
And nothing that we do here is worth any of you are going to jail for any amount
of time.
So I didn't mean to make light of how hard that is.
And,
and how difficult that can be.
and it's not just for me,
not just for the seals,
but you know,
the marines just soldiers that were there who are dealing with,
like I said,
they're doing with younger kids and,
and uh,
less with less training.
And you know,
those,
when you come in the seal teams,
you came in because he wanted to go to combat.
Like every single CEO wants to go to combat.
They want to be there.
I don't know if you've ever heard my retirement speech.
It's,
it's,
it's on youtube.
But when like I made a list and said,
hey,
if you want to go over to the eastern part of Ramadi and live in,
uh,
in,
blown out bunker and get into firefights every day,
put your name on this list.
And I walked out of the room,
I came back 20 minutes later and every single guy in the task unit had their
name on the list.
So we're,
we're you with guys at every single guy.
That's what they want to do.
Now.
Do they get tired?
Do they get combat stress?
They absolutely do.
Do they get scared?
Yes they do.
It's,
it's hard.
But we have a guy that at least start from the position of I want to do this.
This is my profession.
The army,
you know you,
you definitely ended up with guys that are coming in the army because they
wanted to pay for college or they wanted to get a job or they wanted to get out
of whatever hometown there in and,
and that's how they ended up in the army.
Again,
there's also a great number of soldiers that are just as eager for combat and
certainly a great number of marines that are the same attitude.
So each,
each one of those people,
you have your own challenges and it,
and it is hard and you do have to,
and what goes back to what this whole thing has been about as the leader,
you can't be the one that's getting wrapped up in those emotions.
You can't be the one when you,
yeah,
I'll tell you what,
your heart's going to be fucking broken.
When you lose guys,
it's going to be broken and you're going to want nothing more than to go out and
rubble cds and salt the earth.
So everyone is dead and no one will ever live there again.
But if you let that get ahold of you as the leader,
your,
your team and your men are going to be in hell,
that's where they're going to end up.
And so that's why the education,
the training,
the understanding of it,
it's so many people contacted me after I did the,
the,
the me lie podcast.
That isn't your thank you that they,
they play that meal.
I podcast for leadership training inside multiple military organizations.
It's,
it's awesome.
I'm so happy that they do that because when I came out with that podcast,
I had tons of people that said I didn't,
it didn't know about that.
People that were in leadership positions didn't understand,
didn't know what the meal I'm asking her was.
And it's,
uh,
it's one of the darkest stains on our history.
But you have to talk about it and you talked earlier about,
hey,
I don't want to make it.
I didn't really want to go into too much of what led up to it cause I didn't
want to make excuses,
man.
I went into detail of why it happened because I want everyone to understand all
those little things.
How when you cut those corners,
how when you play the telephone game with your intelligence and you let people
say things that you don't put them in check and you don't,
you let them use words that are correct and you've people that don't have a
culture to ask why we're doing this.
And you set those situations up and you let bad leaders into situate or in
positions that they shouldn't be Cali failing out of ocs multiple times.
Like that's it.
That's it.
You let those things happen and you're going to end up in hell and as a leader,
that's your job to stop it.
Yeah.
That's a good place to wrap it up,
man.
Me Lie.
You lie.
It didn't necessarily happen on March,
1619 68 it happened when Kelly failed.
It was ocs.
It happened when the intelligence failed to get passed down properly.
It failed every time somebody was allowed to smack around a Vietnamese and they
didn't get called on it.
That's when it happened.
You know,
the,
the actual acute incident was just the result of a long,
long process.
So.
Awesome.
That's great man.
Thank you so much.
Thanks for having me on.
Thanks for you guys for what you do and you guys put out kick ass podcasts and I
appreciate listening to them.
And then maybe we'll get to do this again
in South Dakota as well.
I mean,
I can tell you from my own personal,
uh,
experience,
listen to your podcasts as well as a lot of guys I know of all ages,
guys from high school all the way on up into their 50s or one guy that I know is
a huge fan.
Um,
you know,
I don't want to,
it's just a three of us and it's getting a little sweaty in here already,
so I won't get on my knees too much.
But,
uh,
it's not an a,
it's not an exaggeration to say that you're changing people's lives,
so thank you and keep it up.
I mean,
we've had a great effect on me personally,
so thank you.
Thanks Barbara.
Thanks for listening.
Thanks guys.
And that wraps up the conversation and thanks for listening and thanks to Daryl
Cooper and Danieli Bilali for organizing that discussion.
And I look forward to having some more of those types of conversations in the
future about history and about human nature and about leadership.
And in the meantime,
Echo.
Yes.
Speaking of leadership,
if people want to lead themselves down the right path,
the path,
yes.
Do you have any maybe recommendations for them?
Sure,
of course they do.
So we're all working out,
right?
Yeah.
Every day.
You work out every day.
Although I got sick,
he's just straight up at arrest.
Yeah.
Flu,
flu.
Yeah.
You know what that is?
Yeah,
man,
I hear bad things.
Yeah.
No,
it wasn't your shot did.
I didn't get that.
Amen.
You know,
I hear mixed reviews about the whole flute deal.
Either way,
you're obviously better.
You seem better and better,
which is good because now you can get back to working out and when you get back
to working out,
you still want to maintain your joint sick or not sick,
maintain your joints.
That's what I think.
I think everyone would agree with me on that one and the way you maintain your
joints is to take joint supplements like Krill oil,
Jocko,
super krill oil.
That's the good one.
Talk with supplements.
That's right.
Also a good supplement called joint warfare.
I take those every single day,
every single day.
No version,
no slack,
no slack unless you run out,
but here's the thing,
you don't have to run out anymore.
You subscribe,
you get the subscription situation.
Everyone,
30 days,
60 days,
whatever,
however much you use or whatever.
You got an estimate and then boom,
you do your subscription and you get one in the mail every month.
Never run out.
Maintain the joints.
Important.
More important than your power mass gainer 5,000 I think so too.
Yeah.
Also you want some cognitive enhancements which you do.
You do.
You totally do.
Brothers like you know,
cell phone signals and you know pollutions,
pollutants from cars.
That's a mess up your brain.
Sometimes you need some cognitive enhancement.
Jock was another supplement called discipline.
It's a pre mission cognitive,
physical enhancement,
cognitive enhancement,
all in one boom and it tastes good.
Boom.
Take it.
I would say take that everyday you take it before stuff.
So you call it a pre mission indicates you take it
or you do something where you even before it,
before I do a mission,
that mission could be going to work with a company like hey I'm going to need to
be on my a game mentally and cause we're solving problems for digging in the
leadership situations.
We're finding out what's going on.
Any game has got a calm also Jujitsu.
Yeah.
But the people always say,
well I thought you didn't take preop workouts and I don't.
Not for a workout.
Oh yeah.
For the workouts.
I mean I might do that one out of every 10 workouts,
maybe even 21 I take some kind of a pre pre workout.
Yeah.
It's cause when I wake up in the morning I'm not hungry.
Not even third.
I mean I drink water,
but I'm not like that.
I don't feel the need for some jack me up during the workout and I'm just going
to go get it.
Yeah.
And you don't really drink coffee so you don't even have that situation.
You know?
I don't like coffee and people will ask why I don't like coffee.
Don't like the taste of it tastes horrible.
Yes.
So what that did,
is it like it made you or it didn't allow you to get into the coffee system?
Because that's really what it is.
I mean,
I hate to call and everyone says it's an acquired taste.
My question is when something is an acquired taste,
how many times do you have to drink something that's socks before you're like,
okay,
I like the smell.
You acquire that.
Uh,
yeah man.
And there was an,
to me there was no,
it wasn't like,
Hey,
if I can get this,
if I can start liking this,
I'll be,
I'll be stronger.
Not,
I wasn't going to happen.
It was like,
Hey,
if I start liking us and I'll spend $4 a day at a coffee store,
no,
not happening.
Well usually,
I mean like beer,
right?
When you first drink beer typically tastes that you don't like is I am not good
with any acquired taste.
No,
not chocolate milk.
Chocolate milk.
Right off the bat everyone immediately acquired,
yeah wait to try the milk.
That's not an acquired taste.
Yeah.
And that's probably why you make things taste good because you don't,
you're not down for the whole acquired situation or taste well.
Okay.
So like beer,
coffee is the same deal because there's a,
there's a benefit beyond just the taste.
So beer is like,
yeah,
you get drunk or whatever and people like that,
but it's like Dang the beers kind of this barrier.
Like I wish it tasted better,
blah blah blah.
That's why they do Jello shots,
you know,
just get in there anyway.
So after a while you're like,
you know what all endure the taste to get a bit of venture.
You like the taste.
You ended up liking the taste because you can kind of recognize certain,
you know,
there's all kinds of things.
Same thing with coffee.
You kind of start to like the taste because the originally,
initially you want to get the boost,
the caffeine boost.
Well the good thing is with,
with the products that we make,
there's no,
they're not acquired taste this taste good.
Direct.
A delicious can just get taste correct from the get go.
And just this discipline pre mission is no exception.
Tastes good.
It's like a lemon lime.
Is that the official flavor official lemon lime official.
Yeah.
That's a good one because that's like a real like broad,
like most people are gonna like the lemon lime.
Yeah.
Like it takes a Weirdo than not like lemon.
Now you've got to,
it's not that that's a bad thing you're probably missed,
but nonetheless it does taste good.
I will agree with that.
And I think it's one of those deals where you can just take it even if it's not
right before some stuff I just drink it.
Sometimes I'm just straight up wants something sweet,
just trade out.
It's all good for your brain and stuff.
Yeah,
man.
Is that a lack of discipline?
I want something sweet.
No,
because unless it's like a bad thing because you think about you want to break
it down.
What makes something a lack of discipline?
It's like when you slipped,
when it's like goes beyond your intentions,
right?
If you intend to do something but then it's like,
oh my immediate,
no payoff is going to kind of get in the way or whatever.
Then that's why it's okay to be like,
tomorrow I'm going to have a mint chocolate chip milkshake.
Yeah.
It kinda is.
Not Today,
tomorrow,
but if that deviated from your original whole plan,
then it's lack of discipline.
Like if you're like,
oh,
I'm really craving a shake.
I won't have it today but I'll have it tomorrow.
Even though the plan is doesn't entail you having it tomorrow,
man.
It's like a lack of discipline just on a bigger scale I guess,
or more belong longevity,
skill check.
Nonetheless.
Discipline.
It's good.
Tastes good.
It feels good.
It won't take discipline to take discipline knows what I'm saying?
Like cause it's going to taste good.
It's going to make your,
you're saying you know what it is when you take it.
I was talking to Jane about this.
It's like a,
um,
you know how like when you're searching for a word,
you know when you're trying to explain something and like let's say out of know
your brain is off.
You're hung over four year,
didn't get enough sleep or whatever and you're searching,
oh what's that word again?
Or you forget someone's name like your friend or something like this.
It's almost like the discipline is going to connect those dots for you.
Yeah.
And this is what it feels like.
You don't feel like,
you know what you ever played the lottery like power ball or something?
Not really cool.
You ever seen like on the news how they get the balls?
Yeah.
It's like this big around cage that they spin and all the,
all the balls fly around in there and then they just kind of,
one randomly comes into the little shoot there.
It's what it feels like.
It's like that's all the words.
It's your brain and that's all the words and man that correct words just not
shoot.
He's not coming in there.
You know what I mean?
But the discipline shoots the right words in there like no,
like one speed,
boom,
boom.
See what I'm saying?
That's what it feels like.
Take this one when the lottery to check.
Yup.
Same exact thing nonetheless as good.
Get that@originmain.com that's where you can get all this stuff.
Origin labs,
they're producing it by the truckload for us.
Okay.
Also an origin main.com there's some good keys on there.
Really good.
[inaudible] only gives,
I'm wearing now forever.
Forever.
Straight up.
And they're made in America.
By the way,
the cottons made in America sewn in America.
Lu Loom is not a verb woven with looms.
Wrong word,
lottery.
Just pop
to do a verb.
Maybe that's proactive.
It's true.
See,
hey,
what?
Shakespeare made up a word.
Everyone was cool with it.
All of a sudden that came cool.
And you can make words.
All you need is people to sign up.
So you know why the cotton is straight up loomed in America and sold and you
assembled in them.
They're made in America,
straight up the GIES,
this rash guards on their compression gear,
if you will,
pants and tops.
By the way,
it's not just cotton,
you know?
That's why it's so different.
Yeah.
Because it's,
it's,
it's a hybrid blend.
It's not just cotton.
All right.
So yeah,
there's that.
That's why the material dries quicker.
That's why it's antimicrobrial type doesn't smell bad.
That's why it dries out quick.
That's why it's lighter because it's,
it's made from the get go for Jujitsu.
Yeah.
So yeah,
and that is a big deal.
If you,
if you take Jujitsu and you even just pay even that much attention to that kind
of stuff,
it makes a difference.
And then tried to go back to your old g,
you can be like,
Brent,
why don't even do that to my origin sticking with it.
That's why I'm sticking with it.
Also,
speaking of,
did you have to,
there's an immersion camp.
Yeah.
Coming up or August 26 through September 2nd is to two sessions.
Right.
Early late session.
I'm going,
Jackie going,
I am going both sessions.
Port Jocko was so mad he couldn't participate last time.
Yeah.
He was almost like something.
Was there just bothering you the whole time?
Oh No,
no.
A lot.
Yeah.
Well he didn't show it that much,
but you could tell.
Well yeah,
I wouldn't say I let it get to me.
Right.
But it definitely bothered me.
It would show every,
every once in awhile unless Jack will be there in full effect this time.
And uh,
yeah,
I'll be there and uh,
you know,
we can immerse ourselves in Jujitsu.
That's what it is.
It's not a bootcamp.
August 26 through September 2nd yeah.
That's a good one.
Coming to origin.
Yeah.
So go to origin main.com you can look at literally all of these.
It's immersion.
It's you through immersion camp.
You can only do Jujitsu.
How many days,
how many hours a day can you do Jujitsu?
What in real life or in the camp?
In the camp and in real life.
I guess technically in the camp you can do it for 24 hours.
Really technically,
if you really want to know realistically,
what do you think someone does?
Two or three hours in the morning and two or three hours in the afternoon or
bed,
two hours in the morning,
two hours in the afternoon,
two hours in the evening,
six hours a day.
Yeah.
Be Sore.
If you're going getting after it,
which you're not obligated to do,
but that's the freedom you have and that's how good it is.
And that's the thing,
man.
So you know how like let's say you for example,
yeah.
And you're like,
Hey,
I want to on a rule,
two hours in the morning,
two hours afternoon,
two hours at night.
I,
but here's the thing,
you can't just decide to roll.
You got to roll with somebody,
otherwise you just rolling by yourself.
So that's a problem in the real world.
Not everyone you know,
but this camp,
oh yeah.
Every single time.
Pining people,
by the way,
all levels.
Boom.
So yeah,
get some,
even if you've never done Jujitsu,
ever still go and learn some shit to get off to [inaudible].
It's a good way to look.
The ground running.
Immersion.
Yup.
Fully or domain.com check.
Look at all this stuff and you know Dave Burke's coming by the way.
Yeah.
I'm looking forward to them.
Lister Immersion Jujitsu in time.
Dave Burke calls me.
I see his name pop up on my phone.
Like you know,
every once in a while you'll run into that guy who can give you that feeling
like,
oh gosh,
Dave Brooks calling me.
Yeah,
good deal.
Did it kind of like brightens your day?
A little new?
I don't know what else is coming.
I don't know if JP is going to calm her life.
Yeah.
Gotta check the schedules.
Got To block the F team schedules.
Yeah,
that'd be good if both of them come.
They've been,
I've been noticing they've been getting their train on or trying to train.
Yeah,
man.
That's good.
Also,
speaking of the training,
if you want some good fitness gear,
mix up the workout,
keep more creative with the workout with the movements and equipment.
Could have [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko get yourself some primal bells.
I highly recommend.
By the way,
someone hit me up because we had this conversation last time.
You said that my workouts were boring.
Yeah.
And someone kind of sided with me just so you know.
Cool.
Cause I said the workouts can be boring if you're boring,
right?
Yeah we did.
But the thing is we did people sided with me.
Well they're right and,
and straight up.
You're right.
Because I think we kind of concluded that to where,
yeah,
you know,
if you're boring or if you intentionally make it boring,
it's boring.
That's how,
in fact the board ill,
the boredom and the boringness of the workout can be part of a certain type of
training.
You know,
it's like a mental endurance training yet.
So it's a whole big thing.
And I was irresponsible to accuse you ever do,
do you ever do a workout where you just do one movement the whole the whole
time?
No.
Wait,
there is some mental,
not a fool.
There's some sort of like,
there's definitely something to that mentally.
Yeah.
You know like,
oh I'm just going to do 500 repetitions of whatever this is.
Actually.
Yes,
I have.
It was snatch.
So get a little snack.
Here's the thing though.
It was I kind of bus notch?
No.
Oh,
barbells.
Okay.
It was a cross fit 500 snatches it.
No,
it was um,
that's my joke.
I forget how many,
it was a dumb amount.
Put it that way.
Well,
at the time I thought it was anyway,
I forget how much it was probably for you
too.
I mean it's already done.
I think it was 200 board FFT.
You powered through those last five reps though.
Almost sucking.
I did it,
but that was it.
That's the only thing.
Super Sore the next day.
Yeah,
but that's it.
Yeah.
Snatch.
Let's not just kind of a fun exercise though.
That's the thing.
Yeah.
Well
Fun.
But the movement is like,
it's more dynamic than just a,
um,
you know,
like the thing with exercises like the snatch,
if you're not focused on,
this one's real simple,
but if you don't focus box jump.
If you let your mind wander during a Bostrom Mexican,
you know,
you've got an eight inch savage scarf.
Yeah.
Very true.
You ever near miss a box jump and it like wakes you up and you're like,
oh man,
I wasn't paying attention.
Was paid the man on that one.
You know,
I don't do that much box jumps probably.
I used to,
I used to box jump like a savage check all your own.
Perfect.
Super stoked that I know that now.
Nonetheless,
there's some cool workout equipment.
Gear on.
They're boring workout or not get creative.
Boom,
look on there.
A lot of stuff.
I was just on their night yesterday.
Day before.
Good.
Good,
good website.
Good Info too,
by the way on it.com/jocko.
Good spot.
Good way to support.
Also when you get these books,
I think I'm designing the website good.
I think so.
I think it's old one now.
Those,
it was the anticipated list.
Why are you trying to get around to it?
Rather the website was old looking since didn't want,
by the way.
Nonetheless.
Anyway,
back to the point,
uh,
when you get any of the books that we review,
including Jockos actual books where the word kit,
extreme ownership,
the field manual,
all these books.
Look,
I'm going to list it on the,
and the books are listed by episode in the book section.
You just clicked through there when you get them.
Boom.
Good way to support takes Amazon as a prime.
One day shipping.
Boom.
Good,
good way to support to buy yet come through there.
Good way to support.
Also subscribe to the podcast if you haven't already.
Seems obvious.
I know,
but some people they haven't subscribed and they're not obligated to,
but if you do want to support your subscribes,
good way.
Also on Youtube,
I want to say subscribe and talking,
iTunes,
stitcher,
Google,
play,
all that stuff.
And Youtube.
So don't exclude youtube.
The video version of this podcast,
which you've been pretty motivated on lately.
We'll say active.
Sure.
I don't,
I don't count on motivation.
I try to stick with the discipline.
I see what she did there.
Nonetheless,
I am disciplined with it,
but I am motivated to cause,
you know,
I understand the value of excerpts.
Now someone emailed me the other day,
Hey,
this excerpt of uh,
not joining the military or something about regrading that during the military.
This is what he did.
He had,
I think he had like a medical thing where it's like,
oh,
he couldn't pass or whatever,
but he still could do work for the military in other parts.
You know what I mean?
So it's like became like an electronics technician for the military even though
he wasn't in the military.
Yeah.
Served.
See what I'm saying?
So like those little excerpts can kind of offer this info,
whether it be advice or just spark other questions and people maybe they
wouldn't have got it.
Maybe they miss that episode or maybe they just weren't interested
episode.
Somebody pointed out or somebody made a really funny meme that it showed you
didn't show,
you make an excerpt,
but it showed like someone discovering excerpt and like,
wow,
this is awesome.
And then it said,
oh no,
episode number attached to the SEC,
sir.
So meaning,
Hey,
glad I got the extra.
Now where can I find this?
So in the future we may want to add the episode number in there.
Yeah.
So did you know that there was a big mean more?
No,
it was on the boards.
I need more,
I guess I don't,
I can't really follow it 100% because it was all in reddit and,
but I read an article about,
there was like a legit me more.
What's a name more though?
Well me more is different memes going back and forth at each other.
But there was a me more and I've,
I've seen a funny,
somebody asked me one time,
they had a,
they had a ball cap.
You ever seen the ball caps that say,
you know,
Vietnam War veteran or Afghanistan,
Afghanistan or Operation Iraqi Freedom of war veteran or something like that.
Someone wrote me up or sent me a picture and said,
is this,
is it offensive for me to wear this hat?
And the hat said,
you know,
survivor of me more.
And it looked like it looked like a legit veterans at and I kind of was like,
no man,
as far as I'm concerned,
you're good.
I don't know what you've been through on the day.
I can,
I don't know what the meaning more is.
I will,
I'm going to look into it
more on reddit.
Yeah.
Very rarely.
It had to do with sequels.
See,
I can't
say the whole,
I don't understand it well enough,
but I understand it well enough to laugh and think.
It's funny.
I think it's very compelling.
Hundred percent me more those means are funny,
man.
The real funny creative.
That's good.
That's a good thing.
Nonetheless,
excerpts.
I do put the episode on there.
By the way,
here's the thing.
When you go into,
when you go to a Youtube,
oh,
you gotta go to the read more or something.
You got to click on read more.
That's the thing.
So it looks like,
by the way,
I was reading youtube comments here the day.
Oh,
dance.
Bold.
That's a wacky,
wild.
Someone wrote,
why are we even making these comments?
Jocko and echo don't even read them.
Guess what?
Jocko reads them.
I read them.
Dang.
There you go.
Me More.
What's going on?
I had to do something.
Take some,
some kind of act.
It's just read the comments.
Actually,
that makes sense.
But here's the thing about youtube comments.
This is,
this isn't new by the way.
So a lot of people know this rate.
We're youtube comments seem to be,
maybe this is probably other forms and stuff where they get worse,
but youtube has the most potential for terrible comments and for no reason to,
so this isn't it because it's completely unregulated.
Well you know the words on a Facebook comment or on a Twitter comment,
generally it's your purse.
You're,
you're a human being.
Yeah.
Onto,
on Youtube.
You're just,
you're just a,
yeah,
you can create an account pretty easy and they can't really think.
Yeah.
So it's anonymous,
you know,
it's close to an anonymous.
So the,
the,
the key is,
or the kind of the thing,
the result is like if you're going to read youtube comments on your,
or your content to a,
you gotta gotta gotta have fixed in,
in real thick skin cause they get,
it's like they're trying to hurt your feelings.
Like they're trying,
you know,
I think
they are and they can be.
And that's the thing.
People are creative and creativity is just,
is a really broad thing.
And people didn't,
when they use creativity that try to like try to get you,
they can if you don't have fixed in.
And I've experienced this Kate and you don't remember when he used to do the
hand out those show.
Yeah that's a anytime you're doing like comedy stuff or I dunno like any kind of
like creative stuff to me,
your stuff now he's really hard to be like good socks and try to like,
you know,
so it's kind of easy.
I think he,
we kind of have it easy in that way,
in that way because if someone's like Jack was so stupid or something like that,
they make themselves look dumb cause it's so obviously not stupid,
but when you do like a comedy thing,
well at,
to me anyway,
I dunno.
So when you do like a comedy thing or you know,
something like that,
there's something of the nature of [inaudible] Shul or bikini girls doing
lightsaber fights or something like that.
People were going to tear that stuff apart and the stuff they say,
it's like,
Dang,
I didn't even think about that.
But now I'm kind of have a complex about my videos now,
you know,
kind of thing.
So that's how I started on youtube by the way.
So I was like kind of new to youtube and putting stuff on when he got an audit
got shredded and the feelings,
and here's the thing too,
but you don't really have thick skin.
I would say then that that time it was thinner in the beginning.
I don't think anyone really has thick skin unless they have the heads up going
in.
So,
and here's the weird thing.
It's like most people,
they like it because their friends have had natto or something like that.
But then one,
one guy now after like 50 comments of like all of these groups,
lyrics and there's videos funny or whatever,
whatever one guy says it sucks.
You're like,
fuck,
it sucks.
I know it's a,
you know,
he gets to you.
It's weird how that works.
Nonetheless.
The point is you reading the youtube comments is a Wacky,
wild,
bold adventure and I respect you for going,
going on that adventure.
Nonetheless,
Joppa reads them.
So boom,
question answered,
right?
Was it a question or do they say they don't know?
You don't use a statement saying straight up.
They don't really know why we're even writing anything.
Jocko and echo don't even read these comments.
Meanwhile,
he wrote that I was borderline like maybe I should just respond for once and
say,
Hey,
what I'm right here.
We're eating.
Yeah.
And the darkness that came out of the darkness for once.
Yeah,
man,
that's good.
Maybe that's another way to engage.
Right.
I just figured like Youtube comments,
um,
is Kinda,
I dunno.
It's not as authentic,
you know,
random anonymous.
Yeah.
A lot of stuff,
which is kind of a bummer.
Yeah.
Nonetheless,
if you want subscribe to the Youtube Channel for the video version and excerpts,
which are valuable,
I've come to know the value of,
of excerpts and um,
you know,
some enhance excerpts calling me enhanced.
Put some music on there,
some text,
kinetic typography.
You know what that is.
Does that sound familiar?
Well,
kinetic,
I know what that means.
I know what that means,
so I'm putting it together.
Yeah,
man.
So you know,
Eh,
when you put it on a video,
it's like you know the words kind of ad and get animated on there.
That's what it's called.
Yeah.
You liked that stuff.
I like it too.
It does.
It becomes kind of captivating.
Some people aren't really good at it,
man.
They do it anyway.
Nonetheless.
Cool videos on there.
John subscribed,
subscribed,
good way to support also chocolate store.
It's called Jocko store.com.
It's called Jocko store.
The website is [inaudible] dot com that's what I'm saying.
That's where you can get your shirts.
Same Shirt Jocko wears every day.
The victory MMA shirt.
You can get it there.
Boom.
Also discipline equals freedom.
Get after it.
Some bumper stickers on their decals,
on their hoodies,
on their women's stuff,
on their patches.
Velcro beanies.
I haven't seen any of these guards are on their cashmere blend directly picked
from the high mountains of Bulgaria.
Uh,
well the good news about to be nice is that they're in route,
in route,
en route,
en route.
That's any car on the way.
Straight up put in the order door.
We came down to the all the stuff and then boom,
they're on the way,
man.
Straight up.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
Christmas is on the way,
right?
It'd be worth the wait,
I think,
in my opinion,
unless it's called Jocko store.com if you want something,
get something,
check out the stuff.
If you like it,
get something good way to support.
Also psychological warfare.
If you didn't know what that is,
it's an album on iTunes and stitcher and in wherever you can buy MP three s it's
an album [inaudible] album with tracks Jocko tracks.
I don't think you can buy mp3s on Stitcher,
by the way.
Oh yeah.
Then no,
don't go to stitcher then for good Amazon music or something like that or Google
play or you know,
wherever else you can get them.
You understand what I'm saying?
Anyway,
it's a track with Jocko helping you.
Okay.
When you go on your path,
you have moments of weakness.
We all do.
All of us do.
Even Jocko,
I think,
but when we,
when I have moments of weakness,
you know,
if Jack was there to be like,
hey,
look,
not yell.
I want Jacqui yelling at me.
I don't want anyone yelling.
Really.
Some people do.
I get it.
I respect.
But personally in a lot of us don't want Jocko yelling at us.
No need,
no need.
Right.
Is Not impactful.
Yeah.
It's a short impact.
And then the galley is kind of like pragmatic telling me like,
oh,
here's an actual reason why should not mess this workout.
Yup.
And that's exactly what I should not eat this doughnut.
Exactly.
Right.
That's exactly what it is.
One of my favorite Twitter things of all time is that little girl from Australia
saying imitating me saying sugar coated.
Good.
Hundred percent.
Yes.
That's a good one.
Yeah.
Notice you weren't yelling on though.
She kind of made it.
It's funny the way she heard it was almost like yelling,
you know,
like she could be shooting are coded.
Yeah.
Very good.
Unless it's practical Jocko telling you practically and pragmatically why you
shouldn't skip to work out why you shouldn't or why procrastination kills you.
So it's like you'll be like,
oh shit.
It's almost like you gain a deeper understanding of the potential weakness.
And you can get past it works a hundred percent success rate in my experience.
Check.
Well also you've got,
if you want,
you can get some Jocko white tea and you know what?
Sure it tastes good.
Sure it's got antioxidants in it,
but let's face it,
there's no other drink that's guaranteeing an 8,000 pound deadlift that no other
drink.
Not that I know.
No.
So did you get some Jocko white tea,
get an 8,000 pound deadlift check.
Next question.
A lot of people do.
You do all kinds of working out.
They try and try the triple complex to the OB.
They could come up with these big plants.
Just drink Jocko white tea.
You're there,
no knees,
no need even play around.
Check a
books where the warrior kid,
we talk about staying on the path.
What's the path?
A lot of people are looking for the path,
but what if someone could show you the path?
Well,
the,
the fact is the path can be found and it's simply and clearly put forward to you
in the way of the warrior kid books of which there are two and they will put
kids on the right path is the book everyone wishes they had when they were kids.
Everyone,
everyone that's read it has said to me,
I wish I had this when I was getting like,
yeah,
me too.
Me Too.
I didn't have it.
How to just kind of wander around trying to figure out where the path is.
But no,
you don't need to have that happen.
So a lot of the path has covered in book one,
but now book two is coming out.
Weigh the war.
Your kid too.
It's called Mark's mission.
More lessons learned,
controlling your temper,
saving money.
How to get people to stop making fun of you.
That's important to know as a little kid,
right?
Controlling fear of failure because a lot of kids,
you don't think of this.
When you think of fear of failure,
you think of like an adult that say,
don't you know,
I don't really for new foot one step out,
man,
that guy is afraid of failure,
that that's for kids even more so kids don't even want to try something because
we're going afraid they're going to look bad.
I remember my daughter when she was 13 my oldest daughter,
she was 13 years old and she was kind of interested in someone.
I was like,
well,
why don't you,
you know,
try it.
And she's like,
I'm too old to start.
She's 13 you know what I mean?
So how do you get kids to come over that?
Well,
you,
you introduce them to these books,
building a business,
that's something that kids don't think about very often.
They should be.
They should be thinking about starting businesses,
earning money when they're young.
Learning the value of money when they're young,
they should absolutely be learned about this book's gonna make every kid better.
It'll make them a warrior kids.
So here's what you do.
You preorder the book.
Now that's my recommendation marks mission,
preorder the book.
Now.
There's a couple reasons why.
Number one,
you don't,
it's happened with other books that I've come out with.
If you don't order it preorder,
then guess what?
You go to order and it's not out of stock and then you're mad at me.
Everyone's,
Ooh,
you're supplied.
Bandwidth is working really well there,
Jocko.
Hey,
okay,
I'll take ownership of that.
Guess what?
Order the book and you'd have it.
How's that?
That's my recommendation,
so if you ordered,
the other thing that's good about it is if you order,
it spreads the word and more kids will hear about it because there's no big
advertising.
I just got a thing the other day from somebody who was a tool,
a social media,
I think it was Twitter.
You know,
you might want to check with your,
I don't know what your marketing teams telling you,
like,
Hey,
I don't have a marketing team over here to me and echo,
we're kicking it.
So if you want to help spread the word order the book,
it's due out April 24th it's way the warrior kid to Mark's.
And if you want to see a,
an actual warrior kid and action checkout,
Irish oaks ranch.com Aiden,
he's a warrior kid.
He's only 12 years old but has his own business speaking to businesses.
You can get his soap that he makes from goat milk.
Very good soap by the way.
It's got a good motto to the motto of the soap is stay clean.
Sounds simple,
but you know what?
There's a lot of layers there.
A,
don't forget the discipline equals freedom field manual eating,
thinking,
fighting,
working out life.
We're talking about life.
Get the manual on how to live your life.
The field manual discipline equals freedom for the amp,
for the audio version of that.
You can't find it on audible cause it's not there.
The audio version of discipline equals freedom field manual is on iTunes,
Amazon music,
Google play,
other MP three platforms as an album with tracks.
Yes.
Don't you know also extreme ownership,
combat leadership for business and life and on top of that Leif Babin and I are
bringing out the follow on to extreme ownership.
It's called the dichotomy of leadership.
It's got knowledge and lessons learned from the battlefield and business and
life.
You can preorder that book right now.
Did you know that can preorder it now if you didn't know that you can preorder
that book now comes out September 25th again,
if you want to get the book when it comes out,
order it now.
Otherwise it'll sell out and you'll be mad at me.
Hey,
I'm down.
You can be mad at me.
That's cool.
For even more leadership.
We have national on front.
That's my leadership and my leadership consulting company.
Me,
Leif,
Babin,
JP Denelle,
Dave Burke.
You want us to come out to work with your team?
Email info@echelonfront.com or you can check out that website and of course
there's the muster,
which is our leadership seminar.
We're only doing two year to this year.
Washington DC,
May 17th and 18th San Francisco,
October 17th and 18th both are going to sell out.
They're going to sell out.
So get registered now@extremeownership.com the entire echelon front team is
going to be there in,
no,
we're not going to be in the green room.
We're not going to be sitting back there drinking warm cups of milk.
No,
we'll be with you the whole time interacting,
answering questions.
We'll be eating,
we'll be talking,
we'll be working out,
but just basically getting after it as they say.
Sure.
Yeah,
so come and get it at the monster.
And lastly,
new announcement.
Roll Call Roll Call Zero Zero One September 21st in Dallas,
Texas.
This is for current military law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics,
other first responders,
one day leadership seminar about leadership in a dynamic environment.
So you can also sign up for that@extremeownership.com we thank you all for your
service and want to give you a little bit back.
We look forward to seeing you there and until we see you at the monster or we
see you at the roll call,
if you have anything else for us,
you can find us on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
on Instagram,
and on the fee bull hockey echo is that Echo Charles and I am at jockowillink
and thanks to everyone for listening,
especially members of the armed forces that put it on the line every day to hold
the line and to the police and law enforcement,
firefighters,
EMT,
ies,
and other first responders.
Thanks for being there when we call on you
and to everyone else out there listening,
don't just listen.
Lead,
take charge.
Take a stand,
raise your hand and raise your voice and say,
I got this.
Then take up your position on whatever battle field you are wrong
and get after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.